pour la ronde 2 du tata style celui
Kévin salut tout salut à tous
bon on est parti se trouve tranquille
donc hier on a eu des résultats de bon
pour la honte on a eu seulement deux
victoires dans le master dans victoire
de about contre Richard rappeur et aussi
une victoire de
Ding pardon sur Google superbe partie
d'ailleurs franchement on pourrait aller
voir je pense pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu
la rediff d'hier c'était vraiment une
partie un monstrueuse donc pour
aujourd'hui on a plein de petits
appareils sympas je vais vous les
montrer tout de suite regardez bien il y
a quand même eu un truc assez incroyable
hier c'est que les noirs on vainculé
blanc ce qui est quand même assez rare
dans les tournois de de très haut niveau
avec la prise de risque de Richard
rapporte avec ses ouvertures fantasques
il a joué une viennoise qui n'a pas payé
c'est ça et du coup les Blancs n'ont pas
réussi à passer c'est peut-être Magnus
Carlsen qui a eu les meilleurs chances
puisqu'on a vu aussi d'autres parties ou
Fabien de carwana par exemple a souffert
avec les Blancs il y a le collègue
pragnananda qui jouait regaizy les deux
joueurs indiens à Prague avec les Blancs
n'a pas non plus prouvé grand chose ça a
été une très jolie partie mais il a pas
réussi à faire mal avec les Blancs donc
les Blancs étaient en souffrance puisque
on a vu aussi Jordan van forest qui qui
a eu normal à ce à se dépêtrer dans dans
la position qu'il avait contre westlesso
donc finalement pour une fois dans les
tournois de très très haut niveau on
sait que c'est un avantage d'avoir les
blancs ça a été dur c'est plutôt les
noirs qui qui ont pris hier à la fin
dans avec deux victoires avec quasiment
plus simple parce que on avait eu la
partie de guerre de guérir contre contre
carwana aurait pu tourner en faveur de
guéri malheureusement pour lui ben ça
n'a pas payé mais il était très calme
très proche de de la victoire
complètement donc pour cette ronde 2 du
coup on a des appareils encore une fois
très intéressant on a so ouest les
contre irigazi on a aronyan mandat on a
Kemer Carlson donc ça c'était vraiment
la la presque partie de départage pour
l'emploi du monde de Blitz il y a
quelques semaines c'est super pratique
qui est jeune il a 18 ans il a 2700 Elo
tout juste
carcène bon ben tout le monde le connaît
champion du monde
je pense pas qu'il meurt va faire une
partie
tranquille pour faire un nulle de sens
prendre la tête je pense qu'il va qui va
jouer la partie et voir ce qui se passe
et éventuellement essayer de prendre les
risques pour aller venir à bout du
changement du monde en tout cas je pense
que c'est la philosophie des joueurs qui
montent de cette nouvelle génération
voilà c'est ce qu'on a dit il faut jouer
aux échecs et pour progresser il y a pas
le choix faut jouer à fond quoi c'est ça
tu le dis c'est ça donc en ce qu'on a
dingly Rennes auteur d'une super partie
de l'eau qui est le joueur qui a qui a
remplacé 20 minutes le grand maître
Bouddha c'est ça voilà ça va être dur
hein pour McDo de l'eau parce que c'est
que c'est quand même
c'est vraiment un tournoi de très très
haut niveau c'est en 200700 plus avec
néanmoins ça reste quand même un gros
gros outsider parce qu'il est un peu
plus âgé que que les autres pépites
qu'on a dans le tournoi et il a beaucoup
moins d'expérience que les Kings du
tournoi qu'on a été yes au milieu quoi
tu vois tout à fait
donc ensuite on a dit contre goûtech
donc deux joueurs extrêmement solides
donc Guiri c'est un rayon un peu le papa
de la compétition aussi donc Guiri qui a
été cinq fois deuxième de ce tournoi
joueur local contre
la nouvelle star montante indienne qui
n'a que 17 ans
donc avoir un petit peu de partie qui
est aussi très intéressant à suivre
et à niche on l'a vu très en forme donc
attends de grosses parties on a aussi
Caravana donc hyper intéressant à
regarder donc c'est aussi un gros
monstre qui monte en puissance qui qui a
juste 18 ans qui est médaillé d'or aux
Olympiades donc 2022 qui qui est
champion du monde enfin ancien champion
du monde de partir rapide qui va
affronter Caravana donc carbonara qui a
été numéro deux mondial pendant
plus de 10 ans maintenant et
ça va être une partie très chaude en
tout cas c'est clair que je pense que
les deux joueurs vont vouloir gagner
donc c'est parti qui va être aussi
intéressante à regarder et pour finir on
a on a vent de Forest donc le le local
voilà un des enfin c'est pas le champion
en titre il a gagné l'année dernière il
me semble hein c'était pas de bêtises
donc champion en titre Pan reste qui
aussi un gros outsider au final même si
il est champion en titre parce qu'il est
quand même dernier vélo du tournoi et
donc il y a un style très créatif très
fantasque qui va affronter Richard
Laporte qui est lui aussi dans le même
style que que donc là pour le coup une
partie est très très animée on l'espère
va être au rendez-vous exactement et
puis ça doit salut à tous ceux qui
arrivent merci Pierre TW pour pour le
raid sur chaise comme fr salut à toi
Mathieu et Matthieu parle dans notre
chat de sa partie résumé de la partie de
Dinger et il a le droit de faire de la
pub il viendra vous voir aux
commentaires très prochainement c'est
demain c'est ça stouf c'est ça donc on a
on aura l'honneur de de d'accueillir
Mathieu cornette lors des des
commentaires de l'arôme 3 et 4 donc du
coup lundi et mardi
bien sûr bien sûr Mathieu oui
sa partie apparemment il y en a
plusieurs d'entre vous qui l'ont vu et
qui ont apprécié le spectacle proposé
par digne et commenté par Mathieu voilà
balance le lien il y a pas de souci
et puis nickel donc pour moi c'est ça
Bruno il a raison je crois il a gagné il
y a 2 ans moi l'an dernier qui va gagner
ça me
j'avais un petit trou de mémoire je sais
plus si c'était il y a deux ans ou pas
parce que 45 qui a gagné entre temps il
me semble et
s'exciter donc tu vois j'ai attendu j'ai
fait preuve de stratégie tu vois dans ce
cas là je me suis voilà j'ai un doute
j'étais pas sûr à 100% c'est ça c'est ça
donc les points sont pas longs filou il
veut pas il y a eu des problèmes avec
l'organisation il y a deux ans quand on
a participé et il y a une VL donc je
sais pas pourquoi il n'est pas là est-ce
qu'il n'a pas eu d'invite est-ce qu'il a
refusé l'invite
on sait pas mais en tout cas en tout cas
voilà les les on n'a pas de français
mais on a quand même un super plateau on
a beaucoup de jeunes talentueux qui
monte on a du vin de forêt on a du
goût caisse on a dû gamer prendre lambda
irrigasi contre vraiment contre vraiment
tous les les pap un peu de la
compétition si les habitudes du circuit
tout à fait et Mathieu nous confie
donc c'est ce qu'on présumait hier toi
tu parlais de
ça confirme et en plus il y a il y a
aussi le fait de pas forcément être
invité parce qu'il y a un énorme plateau
cette année
et oui le tournoi finalement comment sur
la retransmission à 14h15 à cause des
mesures anti triche hier on a attendu un
petit peu dans le vide en se disant il y
a un petit retard mais non évidemment on
le savait en plus à l'avance il y a les
petites quinze minutes de règle en
titrich voilà pourquoi on commence un
peu plus tard et pour vous faire
patienter franchement il y a quelque
chose qui s'est passé hier je vous
invite à aller voir à aller voir le
stream d'hier surtout sans parler et
surtout a été un peu plus fort que
Carlsen à un moment hier et j'ai été
vérifié
stouf je te le dis je t'en avais pas
encore parlé mais tu sais un moment dans
une position assez critique ou Carsen
avait un petit plus tu proposais dames
et et on n'avait pas mal regardé cette
position je pense que tu t'en rappelles
où ça a étouffait un peu les noirs et ça
empêchait d'investisse et j'ai
l'impression que ton coup était plus
fort que le tour des 6 joué par Carlsen
qui était ma première idée qui semblait
de le coup logique et franchement allez
voir ce moment-là parce que ça
promettait on n'a pas mal analysé la
position ah bah tu nous la mets sous les
yeux se trouve tu as envie de voir si
vraiment
on a 10 minutes
encore une fois entre cars scène et moi
enfin je peux je vais pas faire le
modeste mais bon on sait tous que
l'ensemble des coûts normalement quand
ça joue un peu mieux quand même non
c'est pas d'accord
ok du coup autour des 6 il a joué donc
c'est décidé
après j'étais un peu volé ton coup et on
a pas mal échangé et franchement c'était
c'était hyper bien d'empêcher d'imbécis
dans cette position et à cause de
d'imbécis plus tard dans trois coups les
Noirs se sont pas mal sortis Matthieu
nous disait hier dans le chat que la
position était assez solide
ça reste une position difficile à deux
résultats pour les blancs ou les blancs
poussent et ici on a pas mal échangé
avec foie F3 roi G2 H4 on disait que les
Noirs étaient un peu muselé voilà donc
c'était
du coup cette position il y a Bruno qui
dit on a 10 minutes pour mettre en
évidence la supériorité de stoule sur
sur Magnus voilà exactement Bruno bien
résumé en tout cas oui dame c'est 5
c'était très fort pour museler
Queen il a dû penser à ce coup en
maintenant pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'a pas
joué pour quelle raison ça on sait pas
peut-être que tu vois il y avait bien on
avait tour à 8 avec toi un qui était qui
peut être un petit peu gênante
et du coup tu avais vu quoi tu retournes
à 8 par rapport à tes analyses c'est
quoi
oui pour l'instant
on a dit tout à 5 il y a toujours Dame
des 6
on a le temps maintenant de faire et du
coup j'ai pas regardé plus que ça j'ai
juste vous voulez voir si les valoration
confirmées un petit peu ce qu'on a vu
dans le stream parce que la position me
plaisait et j'arrivais pas à comprendre
pourquoi carrossa n'avait pas jouer dame
c'est 5 alors je me suis dit tiens je
vais aller voir et du coup c'est
vraiment plus fort parce que là on
commence à dire BK on commence à dire
hkh5
en cas de fougée 6 donc c'est un peu
galère et surtout je ne pense alors
peut-être que Magnus avait vu mais je
sais que l'ordi j'ai vu le coup qu'il
proposait et c'est quand même difficile
à voir même pour eux c'est fou Béa et je
pense que l'idée c'est peut-être X2 et
fouder 5 je sais pas
ah oui je sais pas je sais pas si en
fait comme ça je me suis bon bah c'est
quand même difficile à trouver je sais
pas si l'idée c'est fois deux faut
descendre mais je vois pas ce qu'on fait
en bien autrement donc
je me balade tu vas voir ce qui se passe
ici ah ouais non mais c'est une très
grosse idée mais encore une fois
maintenant que tu en parles c'est c'est
pas une idée qui qui introuvable mais
enfin on comprend tu vois mais c'est
ingénieux quoi
ça fait trois bon etc etc mais en tout
cas dame c'est 5 pour éviter d'âmes B6
alors que tour des si c'est naturel on a
le temps avant de prendre la case
j'ignore ton truc en fait et je peux pas
faire quand même ah non non j'aurais un
problème pour l'instant je peux pas
faire x 2 x 5
parce que je lâcherai un pion
j'aime pas la position noire j'avais pas
envie de la défendre moi je préfère je
préfère avoir le petit plus que le petit
moins en tout cas c'est une question
intéressante sauf
je vais te leur dit juste pour regarder
voir ce qu'il en pense
X à deux ce deuxième coup OK
et je sais pas si je continue
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire en fait il
faut protéger gendarme C8 et faire
fouder 5 après il faut faire un truc un
peu neutre pour pouvoir placer le fond
en dessin et vous voyez tout ça il y a
le problème de du vis-à-vis de MC5 dames
C7 et on n'a pas le droit de faire
fouder 5 tout de suite sinon on se prend
une carotte tactique avec fuprend des 5
puis on prend tout reprendre
c'est que si je vais en dessin que si tu
fais le cadre en fait c'est quoi l'idée
bon le fou il est beaucoup moins actif
une fois que c'est une évidence
[Musique]
c'est l'ordi on sait bien envoyer c'est
pour ça qu'on évite de mettre l'ordi là
on passe du temps sur une position mais
pour tous les commentaires qu'on fait
à la limite pour les ouvertures on
pourrait se servir de la base de données
parce que ça c'est intéressant
quelquefois d'ailleurs j'ai été vérifié
que j'avais bien joué la même position
qui est archite théorique du début
catalan là qu'on avait le droit hier
avec cette partie justement à Dieu
causette c'est très très bien dans le
chat et moi je veux dire que les
connaissances n'étaient plus à jour mais
c'était très intéressant ce petit moment
avec plusieurs voyantes en fait en fait
c'est quand même hyper dur
avec ce coup-là parce que enfin mais en
fait lui que en fait je mets un fond en
C4 et que au final le plus haut 4 tue un
peu ton flou c'est très très dur à c'est
les conceptions déjà de très très haut
niveau
enfin là je comprends bien que carcennes
et pas aller jusque là après OK personne
vraiment il a pas à jouer dams de
poubelle si c'est ça c'est vraiment ouf
avec l'ordi apparemment la position à
l'idée de fubéen c'est de faire G5
fougères 6 pour éviter de se faire mais
bon c'est des compétences c'est des
mêmes pour le très haut niveau c'est des
conceptions qui étaient pas évidentes je
reste un petit peu étonné que Carlson
n'est pas n'est pas trouvé d'ams5 parce
que ça a l'air d'être à peu près la même
chose que tour des 6 si tu veux un petit
pressing et on le voit absolument
incroyable dans les positions de petits
pressing Magnus et du coup c'est assez
étonnant qu'il est pas joué dame C5
parce que je il y avait pas de coup
facile pour les noirs et ça évitait d'un
B6 qui est une bonne conception
défensive justement pour bien tenir la
position si tu veux souffre et du coup
c'est ouvert pour juger 5 fougères 6
pourquoi tu joues pas G5 direct en fait
c'est quoi les l'idée
parce que ça l'idée c'est ça il faut G6
en fait c'est trop complexe pour moi
mais avec les Blancs on peut tous
presser pour pour gagner
et bon ça m'étonne quand même parce que
ouais Carlson c'est le vraiment le la
méga star de ce type de position enfin
c'est la méga start-up court mais dans
ce type de position il accède il est là
j'ai peur de H4 en plus
et on dirait qu'on va se créer notre
faiblesse en G5 en plus et que la
position elle est déjà dure donc bon
c'est
bon
qu'on a vu tempo c'est du coup qui est
logique qui prend les cases de la dame
qui vivent la classe des 6 mais encore
une fois moi je pose un coup comme ça
qui avait l'air bien visuellement mais
sans calculer sans rien en détail car
scène bien sûr qu'il a pensé
et il allait beaucoup plus loin que nous
et du coup il apportait que c'était
pareil de le tourner system c'est simple
et du coup il a fait
ton destin mais encore une fois nous bon
nous on vraiment on fait les
commentaires sans ordinateur donc voilà
mais bon nous on on
bouge les piètres entre nous tu vois on
est vraiment tranquille à la maison on
n'est pas c'est plus cool les pièces de
revenir en arrière quand on est en une
donc c'est ça reste extrêmement facile
quand tu comme tu le dis mais j'arrive
toujours mais néanmoins j'arrive pas à
comprendre si tu veux ce qui à faire
reculer Magnus si tu veux c'est ça que
des fois tu vois avec l'ordi mais on
arrive à comprendre tiens il y avait ça
qui était pas clair et c'est vrai que
contre la case B6 de la dame c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment le grand
classique en tout cas c'est intéressant
quand même parce qu'en plus ça c'est
plus souple oui et puis ça enlève des
des possibilités adversaires donc en
fait
si ça revient même ben chacun fait le
couple qui t'empêche de jouer donc
pareil d'un peu plus mais bon ok je suis
pas je suis personne pour reprendre les
coups de cartel juste c'est vrai que moi
bon ça m'a un petit peu un petit peu
surpris qui joue pas d'amster 5 mais
après bah encore une fois je suis pas
rentré dans la commission
il joue quand on voit la pression de
Carlson qui tourne toujours quasiment au
dessus de 95% si on parle des pressions
de chasse comme exetera
du coup du coup on a on a vraiment pas
grand chose à dire mais c'est quand même
intéressant justement de voir les
moments où les grands champions sont un
petit peu défaillants et pour cela ben
on l'avait bien vu l'heure des Bleus
c'est des rapides on avait vu que même
le grand Magnus qui a gagné les deux
compétitions donc des deux championnats
du monde a fait quelques grosses
boulettes en tactique parce que sous
pression du temps bah ça peut ça peut
arriver donc Magnus est quasiment
invincible mais ça reste un humain et il
a des moments où il est faillible
voilà tout est dans quasiment invincible
et c'est parti à la main on va Ding à la
caméra donc je vais vous mettre 45 quand
même sera mieux
c'est un petit coucou
ah non c'est bon c'est parti
ça y est mes caméras qui commencent à
bugger c'est horrible
tout à l'heure bon hier j'avais un
problème de caméra je vous dis hier moi
j'ai 18 caméras hier j'en avais entre
une et trois qui marchait
aujourd'hui tout à l'heure j'en avais
dit ce qui marchait
donc j'étais content d'avoir dit ce qui
marchait maintenant j'en ai pas 10 j'en
ai à peu près deux ou trois de nouveau
et Manu tension qui nous dit salut les
gars bon alors est-ce que la nouvelle
méta pour gagner d'avoir les pièces
noires on pense pas un Manu on en a
parlé dès le départ et c'est juste qu'il
y a une ronde 100 pour pour les blancs
hier voilà et on est dit salut à toi
blitzrim qui discute avec Mathieu et qui
nous dit que souvent les premières
rondes de Carlsen sont pas forcément
folles voilà il faut aussi rentrer dans
les tournois pas c'est pas évident pour
personne et c'est vrai que Magnus vous
habitué à des parties quasi parfaites et
hier il pouvait encore faire mieux
Magnus nous disait bah ouais qui était
pas forcément content de son niveau mais
c'est vrai qu'il est capable de jeu
quasi parfait voilà
franchement quasiment toutes les parties
hier étaient intéressantes
à part un petit peu la partie de
de grandes forest on va pas trop trop
suivi mais c'est vrai que toutes les
parties étaient intéressantes et
surtout la partie de rapport et la
partie de Digne dans des styles
peu différents et on s'attendait au beau
pressing aussi Daniel je pensais qu'il
allait faire plier son adversaire on a
d'ailleurs eu aussi une super partie de
de Warner dame dans le dans le
challenger c'était il y a eu je sais pas
combien de sacrifices de pièces mais
peut-être il y a une dame une tour une
pièce tout qui a été sacrifié pour la
femme mater avec cavalier tofu c'était
vraiment vraiment génial super parti
il a eu la réussite hier d'ailleurs
quand même que il s'est pris un une
énorme pression ils sont les sorties je
pense qu'il a pas tout maîtrisé même si
c'est un joueur exceptionnel
on va voir
c'est parti
ça bug tout le temps ce truc
comment c'est possible qu'on est 18
caméras et qu'on en a trois qui marchent
c'est toujours le même problème
donc je pense qu'on s'en fout un peu
aussi
et on n'a pas Carcel et j'ai eu de la
salle donc je pense qu'on me classe ça
là peut-être c'est mieux mais
on envoie
et c'est parti vous le voyez
tranquillement
parce que j'ai pas grand chose à
commenter je reste un petit peu sur ma
fin axe 4 cavaliers si c'est 4
on pense qu'il va jouer aussi de toute
façon carcène tout ce qui est
un petit peu
je pense que ça peut toujours
voilà 13
là c'est un truc de fou tout à l'heure
je vais regarder la caméra 1h avant
l'événement parce que j'en avais que une
étroit qui marchait et ben j'ai regardé
la caméra avant toi nickel là ça marche
bien aujourd'hui là on passe live plus
rien ne marche
pourtant tu fais tout ton possible c'est
juste qu'on te met pas le matériel à
disposition stuff non non mais tu vois
tu ferais des merveilles
en fait ce qu'on peut mais là c'est vrai
que j'ai accès à rien quoi juste
rien ne marche
bon est-ce qu'on va rester sur cette
position est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on peut
peut-être voir un petit peu les
différentes ouvertures on va aller voir
un peu
alors du coup on a besoin de contre
Caravana donc position assez standard
ici car le 5 a une ligne avec dam F3 qui
existe je crois oui mais c'est pas avec
le fou en B4 là on est sur une sorte de
ragozine avec avec un fouet 5 très tôt
donc c'est normalement bon bien sûr
c'est plutôt des C6 KBD 7 qui sont joués
fu F5 très tôt ça change déjà pas mal
les choses
donc
récemment je vais pas mal très beauf sur
une ligne un peu comme ça là et du coup
dans une position très similaire j'avais
rapidement joué dans mes trois pour
appuyer là où ça fait mal entre
guillemets
c'est à dire charger les pions dessin et
B7 souvent dans les débuts du piond le
fait de partir avec le fou c'est 8
laisse cette opportunité là dans B3
c'est un des grands classiques qu'on
voit dans les débuts de Londres dans les
dans les gambidames voilà donc la
cavalier E5 c'est c'est pas le premier
coup qui me serait venu à l'esprit
tendance
par Kevin qui a l'air tout à fait tout à
fait normal
et bon généralement dans cette position
les Noirs jouent avec ces cinq Damas 5
G5 tu vois un plan un peu de ce style là
pour attaquer sur le point particulier
du coup le clouage sur le cavalier
et des Blancs ont plutôt un jeu central
[Musique]
donc je connais rien du tout Kevin j'ai
connu
avec la base de données on serait plus
plus tranquille mais
[Musique]
l'idée de cavalier 5 rapide déjà elle
est elle est assez
difficile à exprimer parce que de MP3
c'était vraiment cool qui me paraît
naturel bon souvent sur les dames B3 il
y a déjà les histoires de cavaliers C6
aussi qu'il faut qu'il faut regarder
donc bon peut-être regarder je sais pas
si on a des ouais on a on a un arbre
d'ouverture qu'on peut regarder
éventuellement aussi
ma base à côté si vraiment j'avais
essayé de comprendre par nous-mêmes
parce que je me dis pour le chat la
théorie de pointe c'est dur quand même
c'est le coup qu'on
regarde un petit peu avec l'idée encore
une fois de jouer un truc comme ça c'est
naturel
après dans ces positions quand on
fouette 5 est joué c'est vraiment pour
éviter les les constructions standard
avec les blancs de fous des trois et
compagnie
c'est aussi une des idées quoi
moi j'ai 5
kevinci en fait mais je sais pas je sais
pas du tout mais le problème c'est
d'avoir joué F5 on se demanderait un
petit peu ce que ça change quoi
mais bon
c'est un peu comme la Catalane qu'on
regarde hier c'est le moment de
l'orientation réelle
on va voir vers quoi les Noirs vont
tendre plusieurs manières
encore une fois tu vois
Caravana qui joue à mort cette ligne qui
à peu près à peu près nouvelle ce qu'on
a pu lire un peu sur notre chat par
Mathieu et puis cavalier 5 qui joue
tempo par exemple et apparemment c'est
une idée de manuscrit F5 et qui a été je
t'aime pour cavalier 5 du
Corbette excuse-moi moi j'ai vu MC j'ai
dit macus 45 tu vois ok ok d'accord
je suis désolé je suis désolé à Mathieu
le gros fail en direct
tu vois écoute mais d'accord d'accord
salut
je crois qu'il va être beau notre stream
demain matin
ça fait deux fois hier c'était sa partie
contre Google que j'avais commenté
moi-même et que je n'ai plus de de la
théorie et aujourd'hui c'est c'est le
mélange à sa partie avec avec Carlson
tu peux pas lui la faire à l'envers ah
ouais non je peux pas
ok
il a fait une partie monstrueuse
avec les noirs on va voir si maintenant
que les blancs il arrive à prendre
l'avantage sur sur McDo
pour l'instant en position théorique de
l'espagnol donc il y a pas grand chose à
dire ici je crois Kevin non c'est juste
que bon il a peut-être un petit peu
surpris parce qu'il a appris un petit
peu de temps dans l'ouverture bon je
sais pas c'est
c'est juste des fois aussi les mecs qui
cachent un petit peu il a pas pris
beaucoup de temps donc
ils font parfois un petit peu de un
petit peu semblant de d'être surpris
donc on sait pas tu vois il y a rien de
il y a rien d'incroyable pour l'instant
en espagnol tout à fait classique tout
ici
donc le but des Lens ça va être de jouer
le centre avec ces trois D4
fousser 5 ça permet un contrôle lointain
quoi si tu veux puis il y a des thèmes
des 6 fougères voilà c'est pour ça qu'on
met le fond c'est 5
sinon il se retrouve dans les variantes
les plus conventionnelles de l'Espagnol
qui ont été joués rejoués c'est des 6 x
7 voilà avec après plein de plein de
suggestions possibles
voilà donc fil rouge jaune il est pas là
il y a 2 ans il y a eu un petit problème
avec l'organisation et depuis participer
donc pas de français cette année c'est
dommage oui patoche il a gagné
[Musique]
une analyse de Mathieu il a fait de la
pub pour son analyse donc allez voir
allez voir l'analyse de Mathieu sur
sujet ou le replay Tout simplement aussi
vous pouvez le replay c'est plus long à
regarder la mature a décortiqué les
moments clés sur le replay on n'est pas
sur la partie enfin on voit plein de
choses donc plein de parties différentes
donc c'est un peu moins efficace que si
vous allez voir la vidéo de Mathieu il y
a quand même le moment où se touffe il
aurait fallu Clipper ce moment au stuff
propose d'ams5 voilà
[Rires]
il y en aura d'autres
il t'a fait mentir le petit carcène qui
a joué la greenfeld donc
et quand il a il a réfléchi au deuxième
voilà
et ça y est petite petite grotteel bon
c'est une petite dédicace ok donc là il
y a plein de coupe aussi il me semble
qu'il y a un cavalier cap qui existent
qui est
normal je me souviens je l'avais vu une
fois avec les Noirs
bon il y a très longtemps à l'époque
j'avais pas de répertoire et essayer de
faire un truc à partir j'avais récité 40
coups de théories je me souviens pour
perdre 42e un truc comme ça
tu étais pas 40 coups de théorie mais il
y en avait au moins au moins 25 30 quoi
et j'ai perdu deux coups après
j'étais
suivi une partie de référence donc je
sais plus de qui jusqu'à très très loin
et j'ai blender un coup voilà toute ma
vie
c'est pas facile de rentrer dans la
partie tout simplement c'est un grand
cas classique de ouais de faire une
connerie juste après être sorti de on
n'a pas joué un coup par nous-même
pareil
il y a un petit peu un petit peu de
stress si on connaît pas l'idée qui a
été jouée on peut faire une mauvaise
interprétation la position voilà tout
dépend du contact je me rappelle avoir
récité des prépas très loin aussi
souffle et après pas avoir joué mes
meilleurs échecs c'est pas si facile
d'assumer ça moi j'avais joué un tournoi
fermé à Majorque il y a peut-être 10 ans
norme de maître et il y avait un Rémy
qui était là qui faisait une courroie
tout le monde il était là pour les
vacances tu vois donc il faisait nuit en
5 coups et après partir à la piscine
tous les jours et il a gagné une partie
en tournant c'est contre moi et en fait
essaie de les coller non mais en fait
il fait nul il fait pas vrai mais c'est
nul en fait tu vois et j'ai perdu au
septième en fait et
du coup bah j'ai pas eu le temps en fait
de proposer nul et j'ai inversé beaucoup
dans la prépa donc je te préparé
tellement bien tellement loin qu'en fait
je veux bien vite parce que hyper
confiant je voulais montrer que voilà et
en jouant vite et ben merci beaucoup et
j'ai perdu une pièce voilà et du coup
ben j'avais envie bon c'est pas septième
je sais plus mais c'était hyper tôt quoi
et j'avais perdu puis à la fin j'ai fait
6 et demi sur 9 et il me fallait 7 pour
la norme et du point il est où hein
et je me suis pris une sorte de de dame
Castres j'avais un cavalent j'ai 4 en
l'air et me tourne à 8 un truc tout bête
donc la version 7e un peu la position
12 13 je sais plus mais c'était rentré
tôt
est friand de voir
je m'en souviens plus et la partie elle
était pas sur Internet elle était pas
retransmise elle est pas dans les bases
de données c'était contre un ami
Instagram
en Espagne je me rappelle une fois avoir
fait une jolie prépa d'à peu près 15
coups et je suis arrivé exactement dans
la position vu le matin mais avec un
temps de moins voilà parce que j'avais
fait une un mauvais coup de pion à un
moment donc du coup horrible quoi et ce
qui était encore plus marrant je trouve
donc déjà bon pas très fier dans ces
cas-là et le mec a forcé une répétition
du coup ça laissait une répétition alors
j'avais un temps de moi donc ma position
était pas terrible les Noirs en plus je
vois 2350 et il a forcé une répétition
voilà bon parti parti dégueu partie
dégueu comme on n'aime pas
tu te dis que tu es de Gour et en plus
le mec force la nul quoi donc
le petit saut contre ça c'est encore une
fois quelque chose de très théorique
voilà ça va être une sorte de grande
fold golf grande fellal à l'envers on
pourrait se retrouver avec cahier prend
ses 6b français 6 c'est fou G2
quand je parle d'inversé bien sûr je
parle des coups tu fais un coup avant
l'autre
simplement donc des 5 D4 OK
donc ça on l'avait déjà vu il me semble
cette position en speechestre
qui joue qui joue autour des positions
très dynamiques
donc
sans les cavaliers B1 et j'ai 8
un et j'ai 8 à la place de ks-3kf6
la cadence est très longue pour ce
tournoi là et il y a différentes
cadences aux échecs
là récemment Magnus carlossen le numéro
un mondial a gagné en période de Noël le
championnat du monde de Blitz et le
championnat du monde de partir rapide et
on est sur des cadences bien plus courts
on va dire un quart d'heure chacun avec
du rajout de temps et 3000 chacun avec
un tout petit rajout de temps là on est
sur des cadences beaucoup plus longues
ce qu'on appelle les cadences lentes les
vrais cadences mais dans ce tournoi
c'est encore plus long que d'habitude on
va dire que globalement aux échecs c'est
plutôt des cadences à peu près c'était
nouveau pour schématiser de 2h30 chacun
et là au tata style c'est plutôt trois
heures et quart chacun on va dire pour
pour schématiser voilà donc
ouais c'est très long c'est vraiment
très long les joueurs les joueurs qui
ont beaucoup de temps pour réfléchir moi
c'est des carottes que j'aime pas trop
personnellement parce que ça
enfin moi je me partir en fait je me
suis en bout de temps j'en ai marre quoi
et je finis pas quoi et
hier
au bout d'un moment je m'ennuie en fait
j'ai envie que ça bouge et je vais faire
un coup parce que durant ce gonflable tu
vois et je vais quitter cette cadence là
je pense que si je jouais toute ma vie
sa cadence là je pense que je perdrai je
perdrai 150 points facile et je
quitterai je pense
en Coupe de France 4 heures chacun ses
deux heures 45 coups 1h20 coups 1h ko 4h
chacun en couple quand tu avais genre 3
heures de déplacement tu morflais
franchement non c'est clair moi j'avais
des parties bon moi quand j'ai commencé
c'était parti de 6h donc c'était deux
heures 40 coups plus je suis heureux que
j'ai que j'ai connu et bon moi ça m'est
arrivé quand j'étais jeune de faire des
parties de 6h
ensuite il y a eu les cadences la même
on va dire mais l'équivalence Fischer
avec le rajout de temps à chaque fois et
donc ben toi Kevin comme moi ça a dû
t'arriver aussi de faire des parties qui
ont duré plus de plus de 7 heures
et bon c'est quand même
ça peut être long c'est quand même dur
physiquement de tenir 7 heures sur une
partie assis et tout et puis en plus
avec beaucoup d'énergie quoi et puis bon
[Musique]
c'est clair et quand vous perdez une
partie d'échec au bout de 6h30 7h vous
avez perdu votre journée
et le monde s'écroule à ce moment-là
parce que voilà quand vous êtes en train
d'échec il y a que ça qui compte
franchement c'est la sensation la plus
horrible surtout si en plus vous étiez
en train de presser vous avez fait une
connerie en un ce qui peut arriver
du coup ça c'est un peu ouais c'est un
peu chaud
et tu connais aussi stouf l'histoire des
doubles rondes aussi parce que je me
suis vu une fois perdre au bout de six
heures 7 heures mais c'est la deuxième
partie de la journée
tout le temps position à deux résultats
et en voulant forcer un peu les choses
BIM tu prends ta bulle bah tu rentres à
la maison
[Musique]
il y a pas beaucoup de choses qui vont
te consoler franchement c'est c'est la
loose
s'accélère depuis fin de plus en plus
quoi et maintenant il y a des cadences
en 1h30 par coup moi c'est ma favorite
parce que bah ça va vite et tu peux
mettre la pression autant et d'ailleurs
j'ai appris hier qu'il y avait une
cadence pour les jours à moins de 2004
qui a qui qui marchait maintenant
c'est c'est quoi c'est une heure une
heure plus 30 secondes
mais ça c'est une carence qui peut bien
manier encore une fois ça va vite ça va
vite
23 sauf pour prendre leurs points et
l'eau ça y est le plan je sais comment
passer à midi quoi
la clé
il y a eu des histoires comme ça
d'ailleurs maintenant au niveau des
coefficients et l'eau tu sais avant on
pouvait prendre des petits 0,8 en jouant
des petits joueurs c'est fini hein c'est
fini l'histoire
tu sais que j'ai fait un rapide il y a
quelques mois ici donc moi je suis moi
j'habite au canari il y a pas beaucoup
de tournois et du coup il y a plein de
joueurs qui ont un élo très bas qui sont
par exemple le tournoi rapide que j'ai
fait c'est horrible j'avais 2300 que je
fasse 50 quoi en rapide j'étais le
numéro 1 le numéro 2 il avait 2000 et le
numéro 3 il avait 18 ans et en fait
et en fait il y avait en vrai en feed
lent il y avait trois 2002 peut-être 5
ou 6 2100 ah ouais d'accord et en fait
c'est tout 1600 et dès que tu en jouant
va juste être si je fais 15 points
9 et j'ai fini la dernière mais nul de
combat parce que le mec qui avait 700 il
avait 2150 feed il se dit bah j'ai vite
sur 8 le tournage de gagner mais du coup
bah je vais finir un 909 parce que sinon
je pars des points et bon bah on a fini
de combat quoi c'était ça a été nul quoi
et j'ai perdu deux points sur le tournoi
voilà
parce que en fait avant bah dès que tu
battais un jour tu prenais au moins 8 et
demi sur
9,16 par partie et maintenant en fait il
y avait des parties qui que j'ai gagné
0,00
et là ça a changé maintenant parce que
les joueurs ont été remontés il y a eu
un je sais pas comment
8 éditions ouais c'est ça bah les
joueurs qui investisse 100 en en rapide
et 2002 en 1600 ans et 2002 en bas ça
sent rapide pardon et 2002 en l'an et
ben ils ont rééquilibré à moins 100 je
crois du coup ils sont tous montés voilà
pour éviter d'ailleurs en plus des gens
qui feraient descendre volontairement
leur classement une cadence pour raser
des petits prix ouais puis même les
jeunes qui tu vois il y avait par
exemple le cache il avait 1700 hello
quoi
[Musique]
tu vois et voilà c'est pas son cousin
quoi c'est vraiment lui quoi
non donc du coup voilà ils ont
rééquilibré et du coup c'est cool là
j'ai fait un tournoi il y a il y a à peu
près deux semaines et du coup il y a les
rééquilibrage qui était qui ont été
refait donc tu es content je dis bah
tiens on va gagner des points hello j'ai
fait pareil encore une fois
et je gagnais plus 25 points donc
j'étais content
[Musique]
il y a plus rien à se faire et tu te
casses après ça c'est horrible quoi mais
dis-toi que le tournoi que j'ai fait 8
et demi sur 9 ou j'ai pour la première
fois de ma vie depuis que je n'arrive je
crois j'ai pris des points et long en
rapide parce que ben tu en as 8909 tu
lui parles des points tout le temps et
puis 90 comme tu vas faire quoi et le
temps que j'ai fait et ben je me suis
rendu compte après le tournoi que c'est
un tournoi c'est on va dire pendant un
caritatif quoi et du coup pas pour la
fête et c'était c'était en fait il
fallait payer un euro par un joueur pour
pour que ce soit côté feed et du coup
nous pour la pour une fois que c'est un
tornade
donc du coup voilà je suis je suis
c'est rigolo je suis bloqué je vais
montrer jamais mon élo après je m'en
fous là
qui m'intéresse j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
on a juste dit qu'on aimerait avoir
25-50 comme ça gratuitement offert par
la suite pour pouvoir faire le monde le
monde de rapide et Blitz comme l'a fait
Sébastien Mazet par exemple
le jour où je où je
je
25 50
jeu quoi tu vois tu
es au fond de la salle tu fais un petit
50 quoi
on va appeler le Père Noël de la fille
pour qu'il nous donne une wellcarde
stouffe parce que les 25-50 ils sont
tellement pas facile à aller chercher
rapide donc ok moi je vais je vais aller
je vais me trouver un petit pays quelque
part un petit pays sympa et puis ah oui
parce que champion de France de Bleach
c'est tout ça
je me suis dit la dernière fois que j'ai
fait j'avais fait un gros tournoi
j'avais fait une neuvième du du
principal mais bon tu vois les 8 de
devant c'était c'était juste l'horreur
c'est Etienne Bacro Laurent fascinet
Mathieu était là il a été il a été
reversé dans l'open tout comme moi voilà
bon ça voulait dire que c'était hyper
dur tu avais des bons grands maîtres
dans l'open quoi même pas qualifié dans
le dans le tableau final donc c'était
extrêmement dur moi j'avais
proposé
bien sûr il y a pas que lui en plus il y
a d'autres Forgeur belge mais j'avais
une anecdote par rapport au chocolat de
France de Blitz je l'avais joué l'année
c'était à Nice et j'avais fait un
tournoi ben mon élo j'avais été 1300
quoi et dernière ronde je joue contre
et en fait bon j'ai noir je me fais
rouler dessus voilà
mais à un moment donné bon ben je le
mets un peu à un réseau avec un réseau
de maths et pendant que lui il pousse
ton pion Adam et son pion il est
inarrêtable en fait je suis allé sur son
roi et
dormir un roi en plus on avait trois
secondes chacun c'était 3 + 2 ça c'était
l'horreur et c'était en 2011 je crois il
y avait pas longtemps et en fait il y
avait Mazet qui regardait la partie avec
grand intérêt parce que bah si je
battais Baki et ben il devait le
champion de France et et donc il
doublait bah qui quoi OK et du coup je
joue non non puis à un moment donné je
fais chèque et il a deux cases possibles
donc on a une bah il a une case qui qui
gagne et une case ou des maths en deux
et dans ma tête c'était la case où il
m'attendez
c'était perpète et l'autre case c'est un
bon coup
et en fait du coup il a joué il a joué
le mauvais coup si tu veux ou les matins
2 mais dans ma tête c'était tellement
enfin je sais pas c'était évident que
c'était maths je sais pas ce que tu vois
tellement c'était un coup pourri que
j'ai même pas calculé tu vois et du coup
quand il l'a joué j'ai fait le coup que
j'avais prévu sur l'autre coup tu vois
tempo et son roi s'échapper alors que
j'avais ma tendu voilà et après la
partie du coup bon bah je perds du coup
Sébastien maso il veut il était fou
parce que alors je perds et bah qui me
dit mais tu as raté ma tante de je dis
ah bon
et du coup il me le dit à l'aveugle mais
tu sais j'étais rincé après le tournoi
qui pourrait deux jours je suis fatigué
il me le dit à l'aveugle je te promets
je n'arrivais pas à comprendre ce qu'il
me disait et deux trois trois fois
quatre fois il allume me le dire à
l'aveugle je ne comprenais pas
j'arrivais pas à mettre des pièces là où
il disait tu vois crever et puis c'est
la fin du stress en quand tu as eu un
gros à une autre comme ça
tu joues bâti en plus c'était le bac qui
de il y a 10 ans tu vois 2007 40
tu le joues ton cœur qui qui battait
comme ça tu avais trois secondes chacun
tous les deux c'était hyper chaud table
1 tu avais une foule de joueurs qui te
regardais et
bon le stress qui redescend quand il me
parle il me parle chinois franchement
la honte il a il a dû remettre la
position sur les chipies pour me montrer
le matin
je pense qu'il a réussi à les remettre
les pièces oui mais moi j'arrivais même
pas à comprendre ce qui me disait et
puis à côté il y a tu avais tu avais tu
avais
il y avait le prix du tournoi et en plus
le prix du champion de France parce que
il y avait je sais plus s'il y avait un
je crois qu'il y avait un Ukrainien qui
était là qui avait dû gagner un truc
bref mais en gros il gagne 2000 euros je
crois il y avait une grosse différence
on parle tout seul
tu comptes sûrement pour batbacker
ce que je peux mais je suis désolé
vraiment désolé une fois qu'elle
m'attendais sur la table tu y crois quoi
à la partie improbable c'est improbable
même si le mec en face c'est une grande
star il y a toujours un petit moment où
tu peux dire il peut blender tu vois
mais même si c'est bon
le problème c'est que Magnus faire alors
qu'il y a contre artemief avec 10
minutes contre une faire une connerie
incroyable très très récemment et de
donner une pièce donc ça arrive mais il
y avait pas la pression du temps parce
que là ils avaient ils avaient de 15
secondes mais par exemple tu vois la
partie de tournage blitz de rapport
entre 45
voilà c'est un peu le même genre sauf
que c'est différent entre Baki et moi il
y a 18 millions d'à peu près
[Musique]
une fois que tu arrives à attaquer son
roi tu as une chance mais faut réussir
déjà normalement le point
exactement mais bon c'était une anecdote
sympa par rapport au chocolat trans par
rapport à Baki Mazo tout ça pour sûr
bon du coup cette partie donc hier on a
une partie un petit peu un petit bon
c'était pas le même genre mais il y a eu
un petit F5 c'est bien dans une partie
de Abdou contre contre
bizarre parce que les Blancs ont fait
hein il y a aussi des F5 qui est
intéressant pour essayer de restreindre
si tu veux euh les pièces blanches mais
c'est vrai que c'est le centre des noirs
est intéressant
il va falloir
qui est quand même une très très belle
pièce
avant que F5 n'arrive
donc est-ce que est-ce qu'on pourra
envoyer tous les pions à la loi une fois
F5 arrive je pense pas
donc ça paraît
ça paraît beaucoup plus agréable je
dirais ici sauf pour pour les noirs
après on a l'impression entre les
parties d'hier et aujourd'hui de
certains joueurs on va dire qui ont
beaucoup d'expérience ils essayent
vraiment de de tester la préparation de
leur adversaire on a vu hier bon après
rapport c'est rapport c'est un peu à
part mais on a vu quand même plusieurs
positions bizarres plusieurs choix on va
dire assez bizarre de la part du des
joueurs avec expérience tu vois là déjà
avec les Blancs on passe ça va être
enfin je sais pas ça paraît pas si
génial que ça quoi en tout cas j'aime
pas je suis pas très inspiré je trouve
que la position n'est pas facile à jouer
avec les Blancs alors que avec les Noirs
ça a l'air logique d'ailleurs il vient
de jouer 5 bon c'était le coup il paraît
normal même simple tu vois après 15
secondes je décide pour le 4 des plans
très facile pour pas se précipiter avec
des avec des quatre parce que sur le
long terme il va pousser le pion passer
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut pas non plus
aller trop vite quoi faut pas oublier
les étapes
on nous a parlé plusieurs fois je monte
si c'est pas de la partie de péchac bon
c'est dans le challenger mais
apparemment il y a une très grosse
partie parce que ça fait plusieurs fois
qu'on nous invite à aller voir le
challenger juste si on peut jeter un
tout petit œil il y a un gant miroir je
sais pas si c'est la même partie si
c'est la partie de pêcheur mais en tout
cas apparemment il y a il y a une partie
qui est très très animée
avec une pièce qui aurait déjà volé de
manière assez incroyable je l'ai
ça doit être tes chaque contre tabac
Tabeille Gambie roi quoi la variante
chalope voilà et comme ça qui a perdu
hier contre on va avoir dame avec un
très très grosse partie
il est d'humeur il veut se refaire après
ça ça défait d'hier
mais où il a pris plein la tronche donc
il va essayer de faire la partie
inversée
très intéressante ouais donc l'idée on a
parlé hier que plein de fois en fait
s'accrocher à ce pion en F4 donc de le
faire avec le cavalier en H5 parce que
d'habitude les joueurs font G5 mais au
moins on touche pas trop à notre
à notre petit rock le plus théorique
c'est plutôt G5 ici
avec du H6 ou G7 etc
essayez de tenir le pur F4 et plus tard
jouer au centre quoi donc il y a plein
plein de lignes très sympa moi j'aime
bien aussi cavaluation
donc ça y est ils sont exaucés et
cavalier F6 cavalier H5 donc une très
vieille variante très intéressante avec
le cavalier qui vient défendre il vient
au bord mais on pète le centre derrière
et le cavalier on peut le tenir avec G6
donc c'est pas un problème
c'est un gros blender de la part de
tabac tabac et ben écoute je ne connais
pas du tout
du coup est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on
peut le je sais pas jouer G4 ou quelque
chose comme ça avec AG
kg non je crois pas ça paraît très
ambitieux d'aller croquer G7 alors
qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait faire comment on
pouvait carotter peut-être ce cavalier
H5
c'est pas appris ça et chaque et ça bah
ça a l'air très très chaud c'est ce
qu'il a joué d'ailleurs c'est la partie
et on avait aussi
ok donc du coup dans mes 5 c'était
normal comment cravater ce cavalier et
ou de perdre une pièce ou de 8 coups
à chaque
prendre des cartes pour les embrouilles
et
trois c'est un gros gros
la partie parce que fou des trois G6
d'un B5 qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc
ouais non il y a un problème de
retransmission peut-être
[Rires]
moi
pourquoi pas et encore déjà c'est
bizarre
un problème
mais en tout cas c'est la partie et
pourquoi alors pourquoi est-ce que vous
deux trois du coup
c'est pas bon parce que bon moi je pense
que perso j'aurais bien aimé faire ça et
ça allait sortir la pièce tu vois pour
enlever ce cavalier d'ici
après foutez trois ça quand même
paraître un mauvais coup je sais que
j'ai 6 ça va ça va déviler la dame de la
protection
qui peut empêcher le rock et
c'est en pratique ok alors je suis
gagnant mais
pour les blancs une pièce de plus mais
après bon peut-être
maintenant qu'on a vu c'est une cabane
stouf la cabane jour on revient toujours
dans les positions compliquées on fait
des cabanes en Europe plus normalement
on s'adapte on fait notre sauce
Anonymous tu as raison au moins on voit
des joueurs se faire plaisir nous aussi
on aime bien ça
sauf les parties un peu folles si les
mecs peuvent jouer des Gambiers rois
comme Pessac Anonymous il nous dit bah
ouais
je vais pouvoir le je peux toujours le
jouer c'est ce qu'on a dit hier avec le
petit système par exemple j'ai proposé
sur la Viennoise il y a beaucoup de
petits systèmes qu'on peut jouer à
niveau amateur on peut tout jouer on
peut se faire plaisir mais ce qu'il faut
si vous jouez les mines quand même
connaître un minimum quand même
mais normalement vous êtes dans votre
jardin à partir du moment où vous êtes
dans votre jardin et que les il y a pas
trop de branches il y a pas une
arborescence de variante trop importante
bah c'est cool à apprendre
ok elle prend des cartes d'âmes prendre
des quatre
sur les pièces
ok bon en tout cas là cette partie parce
qu'à l'intérieur est sympa on va revenir
comme dans le dans le chat en tout cas
n'hésitez pas à dire ah il a joué
justement posé la question est-ce qu'on
peut jouer comme ça
ça paraît bizarre quoi
ça paraît bizarre dans le 6 alors normal
j'ai aussi Dame des trois souffle mais
c'est un peu plus chaud parce qu'il y a
peut-être tout F3
F3 que je commence à regarder
mais c'est vraiment cherché pour avoir
confiance
pour être sûr de toi voilà bah voilà ça
mais je suis sûr qu'il va regarder le
petit Prague
la potion de la dame si on peut jouer
Dame des trois mais bon c'est un peu
risqué ce qu'il faut madame en deux
coups j'ai l'air j'ai l'air d'un gant
après un tour des cases de retrait
viager 6 tout ça mais
salut Mister pesso tu es pas en retard
vous arrivez quand vous pouvez mais en
tout cas oui il y a des parties sympas
on vient de voir dans le challenger un
Gambier roi c'est pas tous les jours et
là on fait le tour un petit peu des
parties parce qu'on a pas tout vu tout
mais on a vu Prague à rognan on a vu
Carlson aussi
rapidement tout à l'heure avec sa grande
Feld et
qui on a vu on a vu aussi une espagnole
arkanga de ce que tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'on va voir un petit peu gris
on n'a pas encore vu ça donc Guiri qui a
1h43 ça promet
donc je rappelle on commence la partie
quand même avec avec 1h40 je crois
que c'est la volonté des joueurs
F6 sous prend d'un point E3 petite
variante
faut prendre un fichier
normalement des blancs donnent le foot
de casse noir et du coup au bouqueth il
ouvre le foot 15 novembre
qui est prise qui avait le 4 OK
et on prend des contacts le pion isolé
avec la paire de fou qui a déjà été
donnée l'idée je pense blanche c'est de
pouvoir jouer des seins ici pour se
débarrasser du pion isolé et
jouer sur casse blanche c'est la raison
pour laquelle Google a joué tour des 8
pour prévenir des 5 qui donne pas très
envie avec le vis-à-vis tours
pour C2 qu'elle peut être les tours C2
Kevin j'ai du mal à comprendre ce coup
tour ces deux
parce que tout le roi n'est pour
l'instant pas possible mais genre quand
même B4 peut-être qu'il veut juste faire
un truc comme ça ramène ton D2 pour
jouer des cinq
en tout cas oui il faut alimenter la
poussée des 5 donc je pense que tu as
bien bien montré les choses sauf avec ce
BK tour des deux qui pourra arriver avec
un thème unique faire des 5 par exemple
des deux et on essaierait de pousser des
5 peut-être tout rond d'ailleurs qui
peut être si on vit déjà là avec le
problème des Noirs c'est le fousser 8
pour l'instant sur le long terme les
blancs sont très mal parce qu'ils ont
cédé la paire de fou ils ont
un pion isolé du coup ils doivent jouer
assez dynamique prendre l'initiative
dans les prochains cours tout fait
l'idée des cinq c'est
connecter bien joué
la cadence est longue tu peux arriver en
retard
de bois si vous connaissez bien vous
pouvez jouer tous les débuts 5 qui
existent aux échecs mais
même le Gambier roi qui peut sembler un
peu risqué bah déjà les Gambie vous
pouvez plus facilement changer votre
répertoire avec les Blancs c'est quand
même un petit peu plus difficile mais
Gambie Budapest ça a été joué par Mamie
yarov donc si ces joueurs au niveau
c'est que c'est pas hyper hyper débile
donc c'est ça aussi la valorisation de
certains débuts faut vérifier qu'ils
sont joués à haut niveau si son joueur
au niveau ça veut pas dire que c'est
facile pour les amateurs ça veut dire
que c'est crédible et qu'on peut
peut-être le jouer après faut vérifier
comme je le disais par rapport à
l'arborescence des variantes faut
surtout pas que ça soit trop complexe
donc là il y a eu plus des 7
donc attention que fou A4 ça peut être
aussi petite menace ça se voit pas on
pense qu'il veut que vous étiez pour
bloquer des cinq maintenant ça peut
aussi être un problème en tout cas il y
a un gros combat je trouve pour la
poussière qui est proposé par connecte
mais je pense qu'il y a peut-être fois 4
je sais pas si c'est possible
je dis n'importe quoi non je pensais que
c'est bien
ça fait encore là en fait souvent sauf
quand t'as pas fait exprès j'ai commencé
à comprendre faut que je me fie à ton
coup et je fais x 4 et je reviens en C6
et le pion à 3 du coup il sera en l'air
tout ça c'est l'instinct c'est le la
provocation du coup fantôme
qui marchera tu vois donc t'inquiète pas
c'est c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
l'instinct on joue au hasard on joue mal
mais il y a toujours un truc qui va
marcher à un moment donné bah tu fais
des fausses tactiques qui ont des
récompenses stratégiques c'est tout et
c'est le haut niveau hein c'est le haut
niveau ce que tu fais ça mais on joue
vite et on on fait réfléchir
l'adversaire et
clic au hasard vous nous ouais mais bon
c'est un peu risqué
tu viens de ouais tu viens de flouter
t'inquiète pas c'est pas très grave j'ai
l'habitude de flouter
c'est quand je bouge le bureau et ben
devient flou mais je suis revenu
défouté un petit c'est un petit effet
Boké je crois qu'on appelle ça
normalement quand on foute l'arrière
salut à toi Robinson arrive
salut à tous tu avais trouvé l'idée du
dessin mais alors du coup c'est 6 on
fait vraiment
j'aime bien l'idée tu vois de connecter
le fou le cavalier et la tour sur tous
ces petits points faibles si c'est F7
peut-être je dis bien peut-être qu'un
jour avec un cavalier 5 on pourra placer
une petite tactique sur l'option F7 avec
le fou tu vois conjugué et la tour mais
bon pour cela il faudra quand même
c'est plus mon four en plus du coup ça a
pas les mêmes ça pas vraiment le même
intérêt quoi même si j'arrive à faire
bon il y a de ça mais même si jamais tu
es arrivé j'ai plus le même effet tu
vois sur le F7 du coup ça m'intéresse
mais par contre c'est toujours pas
positif c'est pas je suis pas content là
parce que je suis réussi à tenter un
jour ça peut être ça peut être sympa
vraisemblablement donc qu'est-ce qu'il a
prévu sur tous vos deux Foussais 6 en
fait sauf c'est c'est vraiment ma
question qui doit avoir vu quelque chose
de de plus
de plus dur que cavalier E5 je sais pas
et salut à toi crazymines sur le chat
tous les compliments créatifs
[Musique]
hier en interclub espagnole et qui et
qui a gagné il a fait une partie à 96%
de précision
on va aller vérifier on va les faire
vérifier tout ça
vraiment vraiment
donc c'est quelqu'un qui jouait sur le
net juste et puis ça y est super et si
vous voulez progresser allez en club on
dit pas assez mais c'est super de jouer
sur internet mais franchement aller en
club en plus si vraiment vous adorez ça
sautez pas il y en a qui osent pas je
peux comprendre mais confrontez-vous on
fait il y a sauve qui nous parlait de
ces compétitions de volley-ball à une
certaine époque voilà si vous aimez
quelque chose allez en club pour
progresser
il y a pas le choix il y a pas le choix
du coup on parlait de B5
ça n'a pas l'air fou fou vu que je vais
ouvrir des 5 mais casse blanche vont
être ouvertes je suis pas sûr que des 5
combien ça soit vraiment dans l'idée
principale le blocus du pion des cartes
parce que si bouge pas on le chopera
plus tard
et puis en plus a priori c'est pas un
tournoi qu'il aime beaucoup jouer la
cadence est très très lente tout le
monde est content en fait voilà
à part nous parce qu'on aurait bien aimé
le voir mais en tout cas que ce soit
l'organe non mais leur gars a beaucoup
de joueurs il y a beaucoup maintenant il
y a une densité de joueurs de haut
niveau plus importante avec toutes les
jeunes pousses et du coup bah ouais il y
a faveur au joueur comme Carlsen digne
c'est normal pour moi plus les tous
meilleurs jeunes quoi
la question people il a une copine
Magnus
tu es intéressé Sky Bob
moi je sais pas je dirais non mais j'en
sais rien
répondre parce que il est plus au fait
c'est Robinson qui s'occupe de ces
questions là non stouffe
il est là pour ça j'espère qu'il va
revenir rapidement pour cette question
voilà les questions people on va nommer
Robinson spécialiste ça paraît normal
après c'est pas une partie pour le
candidat non c'est un tournoi c'est un
tournoi normal
niveau Potter généralement je suis pas
si mauvais mais
la vie de carcène pourtant de très haut
niveau
je suis pas mal ah tu crois qu'il a une
copine bah tu vois dès que c'est
international Robinson il est là
il est facile il est facile je me
doutais
donc ouais bon du coup dans cette
position on peut peut-être on voit bon
pour moi les Noirs ils ont réussi à
bloquer on va aller voir un petit peu
tout le monde on a quelques quelques
joueurs qu'on n'a pas encore vu et il y
a une partie particulière bizarre ici
bon c'est quand même deux clients pour
pour la partie bizarre on avait dit que
c'est deux joueurs très créatifs qui
pouvait nous régaler avec une partie
assez marrante et donc là on a une
partie très bizarre effectivement on va
regarder un peu ce qui se passe il n'y a
une cavalcade en cours cavalcade de
Richard importante
donc un début très solide
ok tour 1 G4 C4 donc jusqu'à il me
semble qu'il y a pas eu de
surprise prise qui avait le prendre des
cartes donc ça c'est normal aussi Kevin
ça je connais pas
là je sais plus je sais plus jusqu'à
Tourer 4 C4 c'était dans les standards
et bon oui ça doit être théorique
forcément c'est sûrement quelque chose
de théorique qu'avec une fourchette
attention il y a tourner intermédiaire
qui a une sac la dame c'est une fausse
fourchette et maintenant en fait il y a
un petit problème pour pour les blancs
parce que si soit je bouge madame et
dans ce cas là je ferme ma tour
je bouge ma tour mais du coup il me
casse ma structure après l'échange soit
je prends là et après je peux voir
peut-être pour jouer un tour bien donc
avoir un peu de la partie ça va se
calmer direct après
[Musique]
tourbéennes peut-être
et je te fixe ton fou
qui pourra plus rocker
en tout cas
vraiment vraiment
très solidement un peu trop solide même
je dirais et là du coup c'est assez cool
ce qui se passe ici alors est-ce qu'on
peut revenir sur un petit caractère
qu'on a quasiment pas vu
il faudra pas qu'on oublie Riga ici je
crois que c'est le seul échiquier qu'on
a pas vu mais on va aller voir
il est où je crois pas qu'on trouve
assez effectivement
on a vu très très vite fait c'était la
fameuse grimpette à l'envers
ok prise
où j'ai deux
TACs
ok donc un petit blocus sur cash blanche
ici oui
est-ce que tu veux bien revenir sur
trouver 8 au 8e coup
et tour B8 petit rock D4 c'est une prépa
il me semble que j'ai déjà joué ça sur
Internet d'ailleurs à un moment
et du coup oui tu laisses le pion c'est
6 par contre si tu le croques fait
fouder 7 qui force les changes du foot
de casse blanche stouf ensuite le
cavalier va dégager à un moment tu as
repris de la dame et tu pourras balancer
H5 H4 avec grosses attaque
intéressant on va sacrifier vraiment le
le petit pion pour avoir pas mal de
trous sur casse blanche et attaquer
comme ça comme tu me l'a dit sur la
colonnage ça a l'air vraiment vraiment
en tout cas intéressant très très
intéressant
intéressant quoi
en plus
de la théorie à ce niveau là
et un petit E3 qui risque d'arriver à
Kevin pour ouvrir je pense la colonne
nœud et puis aussi les cases noires pour
peut-être le fou c'est un peu
F4 et cetera
donc donc OK
pas grand chose déjà pour les blancs
franchement pour l'instant je suis assez
étonné dans toutes les parties qu'on
voit sauf hier c'était le cas les blancs
sont assez mal sortis et là ça a l'air
d'être la tendance encore aujourd'hui on
verra si
si j'ai raison jusqu'au bout mais pour
l'instant les blancs
ça obtient pas grand chose
alors du coup vous voulez revenir sur
sur pardon j'ai mis
un petit peu si j'ai une caméra sur un
scène est-ce que ils m'ont réparé ça
j'ai une caméra sur Ding j'ai une caméra
sur Ding
c'est une caméra sur le dos de Carsen
donc
salut à tous ceux qui arrivent en tout
cas dans le chat
salut à vous
on ira voir on ira voir
normalement Mister Pessoa Steve toutes
les caméras sauf qu'il a checké bah
avant le stream et tout se passait bien
et là depuis qu'on est en stream
malheureusement certaines caméras ne
fonctionnent pas voilà majorité des
caméras ne marche pas
j'ai
à ce qui ça
j'ai une belle caméra sur Ding et Param
une belle caméra sur Ding
mais le reste des caméras donc qui
marche malheureusement
et
ça malheureusement
on fait notre en tout cas pour pour ce
qui est de la position
j'aime assez la position de Vincent
Kemer pour l'instant position agréable
puisque il a des pions doublés
mais il peut les dédoubler à n'importe
quel moment le fait qu'il est pris en C3
du pion B2
dans mon peut-être faire ses prend des
Cinq puis C4 et pour cela il faudra
avoir roquet donc là on peut peut-être
s'attendre à du fouet de fou des trois
et petit rock tout simplement il y a pas
besoin de de forcer les choses mais on a
l'idée futur avec
avec la prise du centre grâce à notre
structure de pion
du coup la Grenelle qui se qui est assez
solide
en rigolant parce que je m'attendais à
une Nimzo qu'il avait pas joué une
grande fail
un peu solide avec ses 5 tu vois oui
mais c'est pas de sa fin c'est pas de
son fait pour moi c'est le choix de il
était prêt à jouer n'importe quelle
grenfeld c'est Vincent Kemer qui a joué
fou G5 et à partir de ce moment là bah
il s'est réadapté je sais pas c'est ce
qui c'est ce qu'il avait prévu on voit
que les joueurs se trouvent ils sont
capables de changer avec les noirs et
avec les Blancs c'est à dire que Vincent
Kemer il a peut-être été plus ou moins
surpris que Magnus lui joue ça c'était
peut-être pas le premier choix de la
prépa cependant il y a plusieurs lignes
lui aussi contre la grenfeld donc des
fois il y a prépa contre prépa contre
contre prépa enfin je veux dire c'est
c'est
c'est comment dirais-je assez assez
logique
[Musique]
ça commence à déconner
c'est pas ce qui se passe je lis pas je
suis en train de regarder les caméras je
viens de voir
si je peux
si je peux modérer en fait c'est de
rester courtois dans le chat normalement
souvent ça se passe bien je crois pas je
peux
je comprends pas
j'arrive même pas à voir
au niveau des
8 au milieu pour te dire j'ai même mes
trois normes de GM voilà te répondre
mais je joue plus quasiment depuis que
je suis entraîneur enfin je joue 10
parties l'année maintenant donc
évidemment j'ai jamais eu les 2005 et
puis je vois en plus j'en étais loin un
meilleur classement 24 70 et du coup je
tourne toujours autour des 24 50 à peu
près mais sans jouer ça c'est facile de
se maintenir
d'ailleurs à chaque fois que j'ai joué
récemment j'ai perdu deux points à l'eau
par deux points hello voilà voilà pour
te répondre
yes alors je vais juste supprimer au
petit message ouais alors j'avais pas
trop lu mais ouais s'il vous plaît un
petit peu de
si tu peux tu peux je suis pas sûr je
pensais que je pouvais le faire
restons polir restons courtois s'il vous
plaît tout se passe bien on n'est pas là
pour que ça se passe mal
comme Piou Piou plutôt rester courtois
ça veut dire qu'il faut avoir le seum
comme Thibaut Courtois c'est largement
accepté voilà
donc
yes donc ouais donc là ça marche
beaucoup hier personne
car c'est la Réunion non ça fait nul il
y a eu que deux victoires la victoire de
la victoire de
Ding face à Google et la victoire de
rapport
n'accepte pas du tout
et attention à pas de métal qui pourrait
aussi
mettre feed c'est plus de 2300 et l'eau
voilà tous les 100 points et l'eau à
partir de 200300 il y a un titre mais il
y a que des titres à
2300400-2500 et tous les grands maîtres
se valent alors que bon entre un 2500 et
un 2600 il y a déjà un grand grand monde
d'écart patoche aussi tu es belge
on fera attention on fait attention à
Thibault on va pas
insister sur ce sujet
récemment il y en a qui ont essayé de
toucher à Zizou et ça c'est pas très
bien passé pour eux donc on va éviter on
va éviter c'est ce sujet tendu
Nm à
200200h master mettre national et bah en
France ça n'existe pas et dans plein de
pays ça existe en Italie ça existe
aux États-Unis c'est hyper courant il
faut 2200 hello mais en France ce titre
n'existe pas en fait et on a un truc qui
est un peu le même genre c'est quoi
c'est quand il va mettre candidat
en fait c'est pas pareil parce que tu
vois sur cheesecom tu peux très bien
avoir quelqu'un qui a qui est nm et qui
peut très bien aussi avoir quelqu'un qui
est cm et en fait c'est un différent
mais il faut chacun des titres il faut
avoir 2200 hello mais voilà après le
titre nm
je sais pas comment tu oui je pense tu
l'obtiens avec ton vélo
je suis pas un spécialiste
et du coup il y a une bonne blagounette
comme ça souffle par rapport au titre de
candidats qui a un titre qui sert un
petit peu à rien si vous voulez le titre
de candidat maître parce que autant le
titre de Maître fit vous êtes valorisé
bon il y a des petits avantages et
surtout quand vous participez à un
tournoi fermé il faut un minimum de 5
titrés dans le tournoi et à mettre feed
c'est un joueur titré donc il permet de
remplir des conditions mais finalement
avec le titre de candidat maître on fait
pas grand chose c'est même un titre un
petit peu voilà
c'est même pas forcément en orifix si
vous voulez du coup il y a une petite
blague c'est un titre qui est payant il
faut l'acheter à la feed le titre de
candidat maître et il y avait une blague
bien connue en France que certains
collègues ce cotisaient pour acheter le
titre de candidat maître à un collègue
alors que le collègue n'avait rien
demandé du tout si vous voulez et du
coup ça a posé des problèmes parce que
se vient à chaque voilà pour le pour le
titre de candidat maître et un mec
passait je me demande c'est pas Yanis
qui est qui est passé comme diamètre
comme ça
mais maintenant on peut plus le faire la
fédé a compris au bout d'un moment que
c'était ça les demandes ne manaient pas
du jour mais du collègue qui qui voulait
donner un titre aux copain qui est pas
forcément un super titre voilà et du
coup bah c'était assez énorme quoi
c'était la j'ai plusieurs noms de
joueurs français je vais pas le dire sur
le 7 mais qui ont qui sont fait avoir
comme ça et voilà tu connais aussi hein
qu'on a menacé plusieurs fois il avait
pas l'an 200300 à chaque fois et on le
disait mais si tu passes pas 2003 on va
te le mettre
en fait
2003 mais on l'a jamais fait mais
j'aurais peut-être dû le faire mais il
est toujours pas passé du coup
[Musique]
tu pourrais peut-être lui offrir du coup
ouais je pourrais dire mais du coup moi
je dis rien parce que bon moi c'est
pareil à quelqu'un de Amy tu vois mais
j'aimerais bien qu'on l'offre et ça
c'est à toi de te l'offrir je trouve il
y a pas d'autres pas d'autres choix non
mais le titre de Maître fit c'est c'est
très bien moyenne certaines confusion
d'ailleurs dans dans l'esprit du grand
public entre maître FID et amis la
plupart des gens ne savent pas forcément
ce que ça veut dire c'est juste 2300
2400 vous me direz mais c'est vrai que
bah stuff il recherche le titre de ami
parce qu'il est quand même dans les
tournois beaucoup plus valorisés que le
type de maître feed simplement quand
vous êtes ami normalement dans pas mal
de tournois vous pouvez être invité
alors que mettre feed ben les tournois
sont à vos frais et si vous êtes grand
maître c'est vraiment encore mieux parce
que vous pouvez vous faire inviter dans
des fortes trous noirs à l'étranger bon
moi je vous je ne joue plus beaucoup
mais c'est vrai que c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment bien d'être grand maître à ce
niveau là c'est ça en fait on a
juste cette condition à remplir et
mettre international il faut 2400 hello
et il faut trois normes de mètres et du
coup c'est plus fort
il y a beaucoup de mètres cubes qui ont
pas les normes qui n'ont pas les 2004
etc et en fait du coup il y a un gap
entre les deux et
généralement plus fort que les maîtres
filles et dans les gros tournois comme
tu disais ben les tournois normes et ben
on a besoin d'un quota de genre titré
donc souvent trois et demi et en tout 5
titrés donc à mettre vite compte que ma
titré mais pas comme un ami tu vois donc
il faut il faut jouer un truc du genre
ouais que je joue trois mètres file et 3
et demi et c'est pas mal quoi
minimum mais en tout cas même tu veux
neuf partis et que par exemple 7 mètres
fait deux et demi ça compte pas vraiment
que tu as émis quoi et du coup c'est
important de d'avoir ces conditions là
et du coup quand tu es vu que tu es plus
fort plus important pour eux et bien tu
as des conditions qui sont plus
intéressantes par exemple
tu pourrais je sais pas tu as un Open en
France par exemple et ben si moi je
vivais avec Kevin Kevin il va avoir des
positions qui sont meilleures que les
miennes par exemple des fois il va avoir
l'hébergement payé plus peut-être je
sais pas la bouffe et moi j'aurais
peut-être que que l'hébergement
après
en France on donne beaucoup moins
d'invitations que que dans le tournoi
c'est assez clair moi j'habite en
Espagne et j'ai joué beaucoup dans
beaucoup de pays et il est vrai que
quand je suis maître feed en Espagne
j'ai des conditions souvent de grand
maître en France
ah oui mais par exemple aux Canaries les
conditions que j'avais pour je le
tournoi
c'est bon avant c'est qu'on donnait on
payait l'hôtel pendant
tout le tournoi donc c'est un droit qui
dure une semaine donc ils prennent
l'hôtel la nuit d'avant jusqu'à l'une
d'après toi donc ça fait genre 9 minutes
plus tous les repas matin midi soir plus
150 euros comme détriment par rapport
comme aide au billet d'avion en gros il
paye tout quoi et j'ai 2003 quoi tu vois
je suis pas bon quoi
ça va être pareil en fait c'est le même
condition et ouais mais du coup en
Espagne en fait ils ont beaucoup déjà de
de
l'hôtel tout ça c'est quand même moins
cher qu'en France ils ont souvent plein
de partenariats avec des restos et tout
enfin ils arrivent mieux à se
débrouiller que nous en terme de
conditions et puis à chaque fois un
mètre file bon après il y a quand même
un truc qui est pas mal c'est que je
suis étranger en fait si tu veux bien
sûr pour eux je suis français et du coup
je suis je suis un drapeau ça permet de
respecter des conditions si vous voulez
pour crédibiliser le tournoi et que les
normes soient facilités c'est pour ça
que stouf nous nous parle de cela c'est
ça et c'est ça et comme on dirait j'ai
vu des questions
concernant est-ce que ça me tenterait
pas de faire un rode tout GM comme Steph
un road truemi mais non je les ai en
fait depuis 10 ans j'étais en 2012 que
j'ai fait ma dernière norme de Grand
Maître donc les deux il faut les trois
normes et je l'expliquais hier oui ça
prend du temps de jouer aux échecs faut
aller faire 6 7 8 tournois par an et ça
serait complètement à perte parce qu'on
sait très bien avec Stéphane quand même
qu'il est très difficile dans les gros
tournois que je voudrais faire pour
gagner des points et l'eau
de les gagner c'est extrêmement dur de
faire des gros prix c'est extrêmement
dur donc ça serait à perte complètement
financièrement si je décide de faire ça
ou alors il faudrait que je trouve un
sponsor mais même si ça commence à
arriver dans les échecs je suis pas non
plus assez fort pour y prétendre quoi
que maintenant certains youtubeurs y
arrivent à avoir des aides pour
justement faire des tournois voilà ça
peut voilà super pour l'instant il n'est
pas au courant que tu avais moi je le
savais depuis
toujours je l'ai su
donc vous connaissez pas encore que je
l'avais déjà
pas si on se connaissait parce que vous
savez quand même on s'est joué en 2009
c'est un terrible
notre première rencontre bientôt je vais
faire une vidéo sur ce qui s'est passé
dans ce tournoi là qui m'a amené à faire
à faire cette cette contrepèze
grandissime
mais tu sais que tout bah en fait dans
ce tournoi j'ai mes deux plus grosses
contre paires depuis que je suis émis
mais la première c'est qu'on demande
dans le nid qui avait triché qui a été
reconnu pour triche et du coup de ronde
plus tard c'est contre tout fois
terrible terrible moment terrible
qui était en pleine progression qui
avait 2142 et l'eau je m'en souviens
très très bien
une petite sicilienne
je pense que tu étais mon premier ami
que je battais et en termes du vélo le
numéro 1 contesté ma première victoire
depuis j'espère que tu as battu des
grands maîtres sous-famenne
j'étais plus et
toi tu m'as fait descendre dans le
classement
j'ai voulu se rebondir un petit peu pour
un peu de sujet
du message que j'ai vu de de sites de
bizarre qui parlait d'Alexis un hommage
Alexis qui qui est décédé il y a
maintenant à peu près deux semaines je
suis au courant parce que c'était au
club de Nice c'était pendant un tournoi
et donc voilà
moi j'ai pas connu ce Alexis
personnellement je n'ai pas connu mais
c'est un joueur qui a commencé à jouer
quand moi enfin avant même que moi je
commence et après bon c'est croisé parce
qu'on est toujours parti d'un côté ou
l'autre mais son nom je le connaissais
si tu veux et j'ai jamais vu en vrai
donc je ne sais pas vraiment je ne
connais pas la personne mais j'ai
entendu et c'est vrai que c'était une
personne qui est très connue dans le
monde des échecs qui a surtout dans la
Côte d'Azur
et voilà
du coup Robinson en profite pour pour
mettre des bêtises dans le chat il dit
qu'on a joué qu'une fois et qu'on a fait
nul en 10 coups c'est pas vrai Robinson
on sait jouer une deuxième fois c'était
un poussin je peux pas de France ou
petit poussin mais poussin poussin c'est
ouais poussin voilà donc ce qu'on a joué
un accession
je crois qu'on a fait nul je suis pas
sûr en plus j'étais favori j'avais 1451
et lui et 1099 je me rappelle que
j'étais vert mais il me semble qu'on a
fait nul je vais juste aller chercher
mon cahier des parties et peut-être que
je vais retrouver notre partie avec
robinsight pour voir les vérifier le
résultat
je pense qu'on a tout envie de savoir
donc je te laisse y aller
donc pendant ce temps là on va essayer
on va essayer de voir un peu ce qui
s'est passé ton poussin 1450 contre
robinside donc là c'est intéressant donc
là il y a dans la partie c'est pas
exactement ce que disait tout à l'heure
Kévin avec Dame des trois et tout F3 et
du coup la dame elle est elle est un peu
coincée et c'est pas évident de voir si
on va réussir à la sortir cette dame
parce qu'après
on avait peur d'un coup de fou qui
puisse fermer la dame
je peux manger ici puis ici je peux
aussi faire aussi qui m'a l'air un peu
plus fort pour regarder la belle
structure
depuis on centre donc ici la F5 pour
empêcher j'imagine la dame de sortir un
jour pour un peu d'espace
il y a eu car elle prend des deux et
bien sûr tu en prends il y aurait
peut-être fou c'est ça quand
intermédiaire ça va pas faire les
affaires des des blancs d'apprendre un
bras en faut prendre j'imagine que fou
c'est 5 c'est 8 tours 8 va être joué et
c'est bon en position juste assez
standard et si pour pour moi j'aime bien
les Noirs perso parce que je pense que
sur long terme il y a des possibilités
pour avancer des pions tout ça au centre
alors que des blancs ils sont un peu
plus bloqués donc à voir
mauvaise nouvelle j'ai pas retrouvé la
partie contre
mon cahier de partie de puppy mais pas
le cahier de partie de poussins voilà
donc un beau cahier de partir
[Musique]
je le montre quand même à l'écran
moi j'avais gardé parce que j'avais
gardé des cours et des trucs que j'avais
quand j'étais tout petit quoi j'avais
des j'avais des ouais c'est marrant de
se dire attends 20 ans après ce que je
faisais et elle est partie que je
faisais c'est c'est marrant quoi
et d'ailleurs je pense que je peux la
retrouver je sais pas si je l'ai regardé
j'espère que oui en tout cas ce sera à
Nice et Nice je j'y retournerai du coup
après l'événement du coup à dire début
février donc je te dirai ce serait une
partie mais en tout cas moi ça a mis on
avait une seule fois ensemble on fait
une belle nulle mais parce que avec Sami
on a fait beaucoup de tournants ensemble
et on s'était jamais joué ah oui oui
jamais joué mais vraiment tu fais
peut-être 10 tournois et on veut jamais
l'un contre l'autre tu vas alors
pourtant on avait le même vélo à peu
près tu vois on n'a jamais joué c'était
marrant quoi
on s'en a fait 10 championnats de France
ensemble on n'a jamais joué ensemble
pendant le France quoi c'est fou des
fois
[Musique]
en équipe finale en N1 mais on a joué on
a joué la partie on a fait nul mais on a
voulu il y a eu du combat il y a eu du
combat et puis j'avais une finale avec
un bel avantage que j'ai complètement
spi haut en deux coups voilà je pense
qu'au fond on voulait repartir mon
copain
c'est beau sauf c'est bon non mais en
fait dans l'ouverture je pense que c'est
pas mal après j'ai pris des mauvaises
décisions il a raté un coup qui pouvait
vraiment me mettre dedans
et puis j'étais content qu'il le joue
pas et du coup je rentre dans une finale
avec avantage et je pense j'étais
tellement content d'avoir cette finale
où le jeu pour deux résultats que je
l'ai gâché direct voilà mais bon ok
de jouer contre ses amis
moi j'ai beaucoup de mal perso mes amis
en tournoi parce que c'est bizarre tu as
enfin tu vois je sais pas comment dire
ouais mon bout d'un moment le problème
c'est que bah on a un gros réseau et
c'est aussi ça qui est frustrant surtout
rien jouer donc au bout d'un moment tu
es obligé quoi d'y aller quoi
oui ok bon là
on a beaucoup de connaissances en tout
cas et puis au bout d'un moment faut
faire abstraction
après il y a ami et connaissance et puis
moi comme tu fais des tournois quand tu
joues un an quand tu les trucs plus je
compte plein de gens que tu connais mais
bon c'est un ami c'est c'est différent
c'est pas comme si je sais pas moi mais
bon voilà bon en tout cas c'est la
première fois qu'on se qu'on se jouait
c'était marrant c'était où déjà
Nîmes non
c'est très loin
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on revient sur
sur notre tournoi ouais ouais donc cette
partie moi je sens bien Prague j'aime
bien la position je pense que
je vois bien une belle nulle maintenant
va arriver je trouve ce que ce serait
vraiment appauvri comme tout à l'heure
j'avais ah oui d'ailleurs il y avait
bien eu la petite séquence d'arme des
trois cavaliers 4 quoi
j'avais pas vu j'avais pas vu d'accord
je viens de découvrir et du coup on a
appauvri l'échiquier mon Prague il a
joué très logiquement cette partie je
sais pas pourquoi tout à l'heure on voit
aller envoyer la jauge être en faveur
des Noirs en fait en jouant tous les
coups logiques on voit que c'est à peu
près égal il y a une majorité centrale
mais ça va pas être très exploitable
dans la finale donc je verrai bien nul
moi je trouve sur ce
c'est le résultat je pense qu'il est le
plus logique ici alors si on vient pour
caravane avec la structure la structure
stouf c'est une structure à la stouffe
ça normalement
sur chaise comme voilà une partie à la
stouffe et il est et il a fait un
clouage il a fait un clouage il a fait
un clouage alors moi je suis un gentil
quand même généralement voilà
[Musique]
au dixième coup de carwana qui amène la
dame en des 4 pour faire d'un B6 c'est
hyper hyper étonnant très très bizarre
il y avait rien qui
disait que
c'était une nouvelle idée etc tout ça ok
mais
de là enfin moi
je connais pas les trois la position
mais l'idée de faire de faire ça et
d'imbécile moi ça m'a l'air complètement
hallucinant mais
et encore une fois là c'est bon
prise
pour défendre attaquer j'ai cavaler
prend celui de fou prend
[Musique]
pour pour les ouvertures bah tout dépend
de ton niveau alors peut-être que tu es
joueur débutant
ou amateur vraiment je conseille
aujourd'hui plutôt les supports vidéos
pour apprendre les ouvertures tu as des
chaînes Youtube je t'ouvres on a une
j'en ai une ou déjà tu peux trouver des
choses et ensuite après tu as
différentes plateformes qui proposent
les vidéos je trouve que pour les
joueurs amateurs c'est quand même
beaucoup plus facile que les livres qui
restent un petit peu ingrat sur le sujet
ou et ou extrêmement complexe c'est à
dire que c'est pour des joueurs très
aguerris que les livres peuvent convenir
parce que souvent ils traitent de
position
d'élite j'ai envie de dire avec des
arborescences multiples et ils vont même
assez loin des livres pédagogiques
pour jouer à amateur et débutants il y
en a pas tant que ça sur le sujet
d'ouverture sauf je sais pas ce que tu
en penses ouais en fait bon non mais des
livres il y en a plein mais c'est vrai
que pour les gens qui qui sont pas venir
nous avec les livres d'échecs tu vois
c'est plus facile d'utiliser Internet
YouTube et tous les contenus
vidéo quoi
parce que maintenant on est quand même
sur une nouvelle génération un petit peu
tu vois à l'époque c'était vraiment les
bouquins les trucs et maintenant c'est
beaucoup plus
numérique et c'est vrai que pour
apprendre les ouvertures ou même travail
les échecs comme manière générale je
pense que c'est sympa en fait de
travailler avec avec internet c'est plus
vivant on peut avancer reculer alors que
même tu vois avec un avec un livre ben
c'est pas facile de lire de lire un
livre d'échec quand on débute tu lis un
bouquin d'échec bon j'en ai pas ici
[Rires]
si vous voulez vous l'ouvrez et bon soit
c'est toute tactique il y a pas de
diagramme etc soit vous êtes plutôt des
positions avec plein de textes et chacun
et on a du mal à vraiment comprendre ce
qui se passe quoi et vraiment se
retrouver donc en fait vous allez perdre
beaucoup de temps pour jouer les coups
sur votre chéquier ou tout ça quoi donc
donc voilà moi pour être enfin moi à mon
niveau les bouquins bon j'en ai encore
j'utilise même pour des cours et tout
mais bon moi j'ai l'habitude de
travailler avec les bouquins mais pour
moi même en fait j'utilise surtout le
bouquin quand je suis en voyage genre
dans un avion dans un truc et en fait
l'avantage c'est que je suis capable de
pouvoir voir la position à l'aveugle et
du coup j'ai un bouquin avec un je sais
pas tu as un petit échiquier un
diagramme et plein de trucs qui crient
en dessous bah en fait je suis capable
de le lire en imaginant ma position en
fait
et ça me va du coup je trouve ça cool en
fait c'est sympa
tout le monde bien sûr exactement on
comprend parce que les gens qui ont
besoin de la réfecter pour voir la
position et ben il faut 2-1 avant de
travailler pas avoir la flemme sortir
les chéquier mettre les pièces perdre un
temps fou à chaque fois que vous voulez
qu'on et au final ben vous pouvez avoir
l'information plus rapidement en voyant
une vidéo par exemple tu vois parce que
tout est possible quelqu'un vous vous
explique dans votre langue ou pas c'est
plus sympa maintenant en fait maintenant
qu'il y a ça mais à l'époque il y avait
pas tout ce qui a YouTube les streams
tout ça c'était vraiment le bouquin qui
me ferait t'acheter des bons bouquins et
les travailler et maintenant bah en fait
c'est pour ça que l'information est plus
accessible et plus facile à prendre donc
voilà
tout à fait et puis
donc moi je l'ai dit c'est le week-end
un petit peu où je lance ma plateforme
de formation et justement le cadeau que
j'ai fait pour tiser un petit peu les
gens et qu'ils viennent s'inscrire à la
plateforme de formation c'est comment
créer son répertoire d'ouverture ou je
donne des conseils d'ouverture qui me
paraissent appropriées aux amateurs mais
ça encore les expliquer ça prend
énormément de temps et on le sait avec
avec stouf il y en a qui conseillaient
la série de bouquins starting out c'est
dur d'apprendre les ouvertures parce
qu'il y a c'est une jungle théorique
donc en fait déjà en premier lieu avant
de vous lancer à l'étude des ouvertures
faut faire le choix des ouvertures que
vous allez jouer et ça c'est bien d'être
conseillé pour savoir quels sont les
ouvertures qui sont bonnes et saines
mais qui ne prennent pas un temps
d'études trop long la pire ouverture
qu'on peut avoir peut-être aux échecs
avec les Noirs par exemple sur D4 c'est
la défense grunfel qui a été jouée par
Magnus aujourd'hui c'est vraiment pas
l'ouverture que je donnerai en premier à
des joueurs parce qu'elle me paraît très
dur à apprendre c'est une multitude de
lignes théoriques elle est très saine
très intéressante mais il y a trop de
théories à apprendre donc un joueur
amateur va galérer même s'il y a des
principes assez sains dans celle-ci
voilà donc après chaque entraîneur aura
ses conseils à apporter en matière
d'ouverture sauf toi je sais pas ce que
tu conseilles à tes élèves par exemple
sur D4 mais en tout cas voilà si vous
avez envie d'aller voir les vidéos et
derrière il faut bosser toi tu
conseilles quoi stouf moi j'aime bien
conseiller les stands parce que c'est
populaire
c'est très simple c'est schématique
et
donc c'est vraiment un truc que j'aime
beaucoup
des idées tu as une structure établies
et moi j'aime beaucoup les tingen
donc j'ai déjà fait une vidéo dans une
vidéo là-dessus sur Youtube qui est
surtout on va dire centrer vers le
niveau intermédiaire entre débutants
intermédiaire pour pas rentrer trop trop
dans le vifu non plus tu vois mais
l'idée c'est vraiment jouer avec une
structure particulière
c'est super et puis on vous mettra la
pause tous les liens vers vers le
Youtube de tout vers le switch de
stouffe vers ma chaîne youtube vers ma
plateforme de formation comme ça oppose
déjà de Kevin
je vais mettre ta chaîne Youtube voilà
c'est bien n'hésitez pas à aller voir la
chaîne de Kevin
avec sa chaîne aussi YouTube et tout ce
qui propose là sa plateforme qui vient
de sortir
voilà je vais tout vous mettre alors
j'ai mis la chaîne Youtube de stouf
assez le long lien que je viens de
mettre
du coup
le saut vers la chaîne de souffle la
chaîne twitch
si je me trompe pas
et ça c'est pas trop mal
la crie c'est vrai non c'est bon non
c'est bon ouais mais ça fait quand même
un petit bonhomme ça fait plus tu vois
comme avant j'ai eu peur j'ai eu peur
j'ai fait attention
il y a un mec qui dort moi c'est plus sa
classe tu vois
tu as l'impression que la différence de
classe entre les chaînes
mais avec moi vous avez un cadeau un
cadeau tu sais maintenant c'est les
vendeurs de chichis tu sais c'est vous
avez un cadeau pour pour la plateforme
de formation allez voir en tout cas tout
cela c'est de la matière et ça fait
longtemps qu'on fait ça donc si vous
avez la motivation pour progresser parce
que c'est une chose de jouer mais
progresser bah ça demande du temps et de
la motivation comme la distouffe on est
bien d'accord sur le sujet et du coup
bah au moins ça vous facilitera les
choses
ça vous demandera toujours des efforts
mais ça vous facilitera les choses voilà
l'objectif ok donc du coup toujours
cette partie avec le pion isolé et
est-ce que c'est les vrais tentes sauf
que l'on a là avec un goût cache qui
n'aurait plus que 24 minutes bah écoute
c'est très étonnant c'est possible parce
qu'en fait
on a quasiment pas avancé déjà il était
à 1h43 ici Guiri dans cette position
donc
possible en fait que que on en soit là
et que un petit peu étonnant ceux qui
sont pas avoir des problèmes colossaux
donc pourquoi dépenser autant
un truc qui gêne
après la pollution elle est alors quand
même assez ok pour les Noirs mais tu
vois il y a un problème de développement
on sait pas encore mettre ce cavalier
sur le met en D7 si on joue des cinq
c'est pas comme nous on se méfie quand
même des temps avec chasse comme c'est
vrai que des fois il y a des petites
blagues là ça me paraît étonnant quand
même les 1h20 des quarts dans une
position comme celle-là alors peut-être
un souffle mais
j'offre pas de chichis avec les packs
mais c'est une bonne idée c'est une
bonne idée et mon pack sur les coups
piquants pour qu'elle level les packs là
on va dire que c'est pour la tranche
elle est 1200 1800 c'est vraiment la
tranche que je vise et je ferai des
packs niveau amateurs voilà
121800 et pas confirmé ça sera 1600 et
plus voilà voilà comment je vois les
choses
bizarres
c'était le le bonhomme qui est qui est
au milieu de l'allée avec les mains dans
les il a l'air assez confiant à sa sœur
de lui et
du coup on va voir un petit peu ce qui
est ce qui fait un bastonnet
du centre assez naturel avec le fou
planqué en A7 c'est pour ça qu'il avait
sorti sauf pour mettre la pression au
centre
huit
donc un concept
c'est assez standard cavalie F3 c'est
beaucoup plus étonnant parce qu'en
jouant cavalier 3 il a volontairement
enfermé son cavalier G5 il y a plus de
en fait et ben bon il avait il avait
calculé qui avait peur qu'elle allait
prendre un F7
donc généralement ça qui fait ça c'est
pas sacrifice très très bon parce que
vous voyez que on vérifie un cavalier et
un fou contre une tour et un pion donc
au final
cavalier et cavale et cavalier et fou ça
fait 3 + 3,6 et une tour 5 + 1 6 donc
c'est au niveau matériel c'est égalité
mais au milieu de jeu c'est vrai que des
trucs et spinner sont généralement plus
fortes que une tour et un pion donc ce
type de sacrifice et généralement pas
recommandé mais bon on va voir un peu ce
qui se passe l'idée c'est aussi
d'affaiblir le roi évidemment c'est
l'idée de Digne et on peut dire que le
fou va aussi peut-être trois et demi
3-25 pour certains c'est pour ça que fu
cavalier c'est un peu plus haut que
tourpillon et évidemment surtout que ce
sont des pièces assez mobiles on le voit
les pièces mineures dès le début de
partie alors que donc c'est pour ça que
c'est intéressant de les les
mais avoir et là il y a aussi un coup
marrant c'est que du coup vous prenez
trois je crois qu'il est quasiment
obligatoire parce que tu manges ici et
ben en fait je peux manger alors quel
sens on fait ça d'un point de vide
et surtout reprend des 8 je mangerai en
A7 Sud cavalier prend un cavalier
par le haut et le cavalier une pièce
si il prend du cavalier bah pareil en
fait bon je peux manger à 7
en l'air et 5 et c'est un peu la même
chose on peut bon un cavalier 5 mais il
met aussi tout intermédiaires
voir si on arrive à
tenir
et
du coup c'est pour ça que du coup il a
[ __ ] en E3 directement pour empêcher
ça mais maintenant qu'on a mangé ici si
je mange là il y aurait sûrement puis on
prend parce qu'après ça j'ai encore
buggé pas grave je t'oublier d'ailleurs
il y a dernière personne
et il dit le tapis en damier c'est quand
la même classe et il fait référence à la
salle de jeux ils se disent hyper simple
Néandertal aujourd'hui j'ai un truc qui
te coûte pas assez étouffe mais c'est
une belle remarque comme d'habitude
donc prise F6 soit c'est chaud là ça se
montre sur ça ça reprend et du coup il y
a pas moyen de manger le 5 cavalier de
rester en fait c'est pas vraiment c'est
pas vraiment un faut choisir le bon
ordre de déviation donc prise la prise
là le foopar et là du coup tu vas manger
en G7
ou mangeant un F7 d'abord mais le roi
noir va se retrouver complètement tout
nu
et ça c'est un truc qui va plaire je
pense à l'intental parce que ça du coup
généralement
enfin c'est tout qu'il est qu'il aime
bien ça on le connaît bien je pense sur
le stream tout le monde le connaît tout
le monde sait qu'il est comme ça et du
coup il est coca il est coca très très
coquin on dirait pas comme ça mais il
est très très coquin alors du coup une
fois que je mangeais 7
le roi se retrouvera un petit peu nu et
il y a pas de pion qui vont défendre en
fait si vous voulez mais d'un autre côté
il a la part de fou qui bras qui sera le
roi noir sur le roi blanc les cavaliers
qui peuvent revenir et une dame noire
aussi qui peut revenir en défense et au
final et ben écoutez c'est une
conception assez exceptionnelle quand
même qui nous est proposé par par McDo
de l'eau ici franchement
[Musique]
c'est c'est très très beau parce que
c'est pas très naturel de se faire
déboîter le roi comme ça il accepte en
disant que digne n'a pas assez de pièces
pour l'attaquer alors que quand même
dame cheval et les deux tours sur
l'échiquier et il se dit que ça perdent
de fou ultra puissant va lui permettre
d'équilibrer le débat c'est une grosse
partie des deux joueurs d'ailleurs qui
ont accepté de rentrer là-dedans on voit
que l'ordi donne une jauge à l'équilibre
est très très sympa on va voir
parce qu'il faut ramener le roi F6
assez vite tu vois elle a eu cavalh4 qui
peut arriver peut-être manger là-bas
en pratique
ça j'ai la tour qui peut venir là après
il y a bien sûr
je l'ai maintenant mais il y aura d'un
point F6 ouais c'est ça
que si jamais je l'avais j'aurais pu
mettre un cavalier ici un site une tour
il y a aussi il faut prendre
mais en tout cas
je pense tout ça sauf pour ne pas se
faire avoir direct parce que
ça pouvait faire mal mais en tout cas la
position très très intéressante parce
que
plein de choses digne qui a gagné hier
qui pourrait finir à 202 c'est gagner la
partie ça serait déjà un très très bon
start
exactement mais par contre c'est parfait
parce que la position est très très
tendue pour les deux joueurs je pense
donc on a aussi la partie de la partie
de saut contre irrigazi ou c'est pas mal
de choses donc ce taux est réghasi ils
ont ils ont joué on avait commenté ça
ensemble on avait commenté le le speech
de leur match tous les deux
stops cette histoire
en ce moment grâce à chasse.com comme ça
je peux pas aller te payer tes subs mais
moi je passe tout comme je le disais
mais moi aussi il faut que tu en paye je
crois qu'on est on est on s'endort pas
mal hein je crois je crois qu'on était
sur 30-22 je tourne en 3 30
je crois que c'est ça en tête et tu
m'aurais déjà filé 5 enfin mais bon
d'avant donc on est quasiment on est
quasiment revenus tu es un peu tu es un
peu mieux que moi et pas beaucoup
on passe à Paris
est-ce que tu veux qu'on fasse
maintenant comme ça c'est fait allez
pourquoi pas là
tu veux parler tu veux parier plus le
classement le classement final c'est
toujours pas mal de faire ça classement
final on peut aussi tu veux je prends un
chouchou qu'on peut bien
par exemple exactement on l'avait dit on
avait dit pas carcène mais si tu prends
10 minutes ils doivent ils doivent
sauter parce que c'est les deux plus
fort
en tout cas c'est les deux grands
favoris et du coup
ok alors attends laisse-moi une petite
seconde
alors en terme de classement et aussi tu
m'as dit un chouchou un chouchou moi on
avait pris j'avais pris Prague tu avais
pris avant de Forest et Van forest avec
gagner l'événement quoi non non en fait
il avait pas gagné l'événement
j'ai mon petit papier donc tata style
sur un de la génération de la nouvelle
génération
moi je vais choisir
[Musique]
la question en plus de ce que par contre
sa victoire d'hier elle comptera pas
bien entendu on a on n'a pas
on n'a pas préparé
hier donc la victoire d'hier elle compte
pas bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr je sais
plus ce qu'on avait fait comme Paris
d'ailleurs c'était pas le classement du
chouchou c'est le chouchou ah oui chaque
histoire de lui et puis après il y avait
un petit en plus
donc c'est vrai que là pour le coup
il a gagné parti quoi
donc c'est pas si
c'est pas grave c'est le
alors si tu as pris un jeune il faut que
je prenne un jeune comme ouais
c'est pas logique c'est pas logique non
c'est pas c'est pas le même
donc pas pris
j'ai pris un risque déjà dans le
classement j'ai pris un risque
est-ce que
[Musique]
pour reprendre un petit risque
allez je vais jouer
je vais jouer Vincent Kemer
au niveau du classement c'est le même
risque que toi
non mais c'est un joueur je le fais ah
ouais Franck il est d'accord il va
perdre correctement ou irrégaliser pour
la nuit les win c'est bien un bon un bon
parieur Fox animé
j'ai hésité entre les deux un pour tout
dire faut que ça donne une mousse donc
j'étais complètement au cas avec toi
donc chouchou stouf
c'est donc Abdou
et
a été très impressionnant ces derniers
temps mais en cadence rapidement donc
après les 2007 il les a pas eu dans une
pochette surprise on sait que c'est le
petit jeune qui montre mais comme les
autres comme les joueurs indiens comme
Abdou satora voilà donc il y a plusieurs
plusieurs possibilités et après il y a
le classement total le classement total
c'est un petit peu pénible à faire il
faudrait que je le fasse quasiment pas
par pour
qu'on le donne tout de suite ou pas
[Musique]
il y a 13 ans donc ils sont 14
si je dis pas de bêtises
il va être beau mon truc j'en ai mis 9
déjà
[Musique]
il faut que je prenne le classement sous
les yeux parce que sinon c'est hyper
chaud de le faire
[Musique]
voilà c'est la petite en fait c'est
comme une pause sauf qu'on est toujours
là
et lui
voilà j'ai fait mon classement
est tellement fort que
tout n'importe quoi
et du coup bah j'attends que tiens et tu
me diras
que tu as prévu
qu'est-ce qu'il est en train de faire
contre
[Musique]
la règle de Paris
en tout cas les gars je pense que je
pense qu'on va l'éclater ma petite je
peux vous la montrer sous la caméra
pas la montrer à Kevin c'est bien
est-ce que vous voyez je veux ouvrir
l'Obs
alors tout
regardez je vais pas dire ça risque de
l'influencer regarde pas
je regarde la liste non non t'inquiète
pas est-ce que vous voyez bien ce que
j'ai écrit tu es mauvais conseil
je pense que j'ai bien parlé
je pense que j'ai bien travaillé
je pense que tu vas prendre cher
alors du coup cette partie donc pendant
que tu remplis
qui est toujours là
c'est rarement le mec qui va vraiment
mais dernièrement il brille pas trop
trop quoi
non mais je l'avais mis ce que j'avais
raturé parce que j'avais oublié
donc je la remets un peu plus haut
et voilà
bah ouais en fait so il est capable un
peu de tout
oui d'un style moi j'aime beaucoup son
style je trouve vraiment très fort quoi
mais bon des fois
j'aime beaucoup la position de saut pour
le coup
parce que le fou aussi s'il est moins
stable enfin il peut pas venir en dessin
par exemple de
pion qui peut être faible un jour il y a
déjà un petit pression il y a le roi
aussi qui se pression qui n'est pas ok à
cause de la prise en H7 j'ai tout F1 qui
va arriver mettre la pression sur le
rang
que la position blanche est beaucoup
beaucoup plus facile à jouer en tout cas
regardez qui qui a la deuxième fois noir
dans ce tournoi il avait une arrière
déjà contre
Prague et là il a de nouveau les noirs
il me semble il avait les blancs ici
je crois que j'ai une bêtise c'était
contre ça
donc tu fais souvent des nuls bah ouais
bah il est solide il est très solide
mais après c'est un joueur quand même
qui joue pour gagner tout le temps enfin
qui joue c'est parti quoi
et donc voilà je te vois te redresser
avec Kevin est-ce que tu as terminé ou
exactement tu vois
j'essaie de me concentrer à bloc pour
pas faire de bêtises voilà je vais je
vais prendre note alors est-ce que tu
peux me donner ton nom
donc
moi j'ai mis dingue pour pour la
surprise
tout à l'heure je me suis dit que
c'était possible aussi donc
Wana
moi aussi OK
moi aussi
donc cars ending guérisseau
et du coup je me retrouve avec deux fois
Prague
alors attends jusque là c'est bon on va
dire mais il faut juste que je regarde
qui j'ai oublié et que je le remplace ah
oui d'accord pour l'instant on en a
trois qui sont pareils
j'ai mis à rognan très bas moi aussi je
l'ai mis 11
Prague
avant dernier
j'estime qui je dois un jeu dangereux
avec ses ouvertures fantasmes et j'ai
mis
max doudou dernier quand même voilà il
en faut un et que j'estime que c'est
l'huile plus d'une expérimenté bon on en
a cinq pareils
un peu normal moi j'ai mis Ding en
premier pour pour jouer un peu la
surprise et puis hier il a bien joué et
puis dans son interview il a dit que tu
étais motivé qui voulait gagner le
tournoi etc donc digne Carcen Abdou Guy
4 car Wana comme toi qui est mort comme
toi
Prague irigazie comme toi
comment praxatiem
merguez
rapport
11e arrondir comme toi
vent de Forest Google
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il oui
c'est pas trop ce qui est vraiment mal
au temps là il a pas remonté parce qu'au
final là on était à 20 et quelques
heures 40 donc du coup le temps on
savait pas trop bien comment ça marchait
là du coup il vient de jouer tout
référent
donc du coup il a peut-être peur de de
problèmes sur la diagonale on parlait de
cavaliers 5 avec des trucs sur F7
dans son dans ses choix il a peur que
maintenant qu'il a le fou en A5
c'est la folie avec du coup le cavalier
C3 qui arrive celui de 5 ça c'est un
truc dans la page tout à l'heure pour
ouvrir la colonne et taper sur le plan
la souris
du coup ça c'était une menace
mais le fond à 5 alors contrôler en fait
les 15 qui empêchait ça
du coup sur cavalier 17
on peut penser aussi à un P4
[Musique]
je vois pas la conclusion
souffla
j'aime bien pour gagner le fou
mais il nous voilà là on peut sans doute
un petit peu ça c'est pas mal ça c'est
hyper intéressant aussi
c'est bien stable
parce que des 5 comprend on ouvre la
colonne la colonne des
fois pardon
[Musique]
un petit peu
il a pas trouvé les clés mais ça faisait
longtemps qu'il aurait pu faire foudre
qu'on avait proposé non tout parce que
il a raté un moment ou pas parce que dès
cedames c'est deux jouait parce qu'il y
a eu dame ces deux fou B6 qui n'aurait
pas pu jouer plutôt 16 dans ces deux
ouais c'est ça ça semblait logique cette
cette suite alors il a dû être gêné par
quelque chose
[Musique]
mais bon
humainement c'est pas simple prendre ses
décisions là avec les Noirs parce qu'il
y a toujours des seins qui passent
prendre en fait dans la structure du
pion isolé c'est une des structures type
aux échecs et là on voit qu'elle est pas
facile à maîtriser parce qu'on a goût
cache qui est en difficulté directement
par contre si le pion arrive à
avancer c'est quand même l'idée et ben
du coup les blancs peuvent grâce à ce
que isolé provoquer de grosses pro enfin
de gros problèmes en tout cas chez les
noix
donc ok intéressant on va voir un peu ce
qui a passé mais ça sent le mauvais coup
c'est un coup qui toi
un modalité de notre truc en fait tout
avant de
je sais pas
donc il y a un stop par victoire de
notre chouchou c'est ça ok ouais
on va l'écrire
et ce que tu veux aussi
qu'on se mette un truc par rapport au
classement
si on tombe pile dessus
[Musique]
on peut dire deux
je crois oui bien sûr bien sûr deux
stops pour le classement c'est ça c'est
un joueur qui tombe pile sur le truc que
tu dis quoi OK
et puis et puis voilà
[Musique]
c'est ça
par bonne place et un saut par victoire
du chouchou est-ce qu'on peut faire
aussi un truc additionnel si tu veux ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'à chaque fois
et ben on met un on met des résultats
ça on peut faire un petit pronom un
petit jeu
et celui qui a le plus de justes et ben
gagne un seul c'est bien ça c'est un
petit est-ce que tu veux faire des
pronos même si tu n'es pas là
comme ça ça fait jouer un petit peu le
le chat
donc du coup et après on fait plus
rompre voilà du coup je vais faire ma
promo
tion
du jour
on a vu un peu les parties mais ok
alors du coup
la digue McDo on va regarder on va
regarder les les parties les positions
[Musique]
ok le deuxième moi j'attends l'échiquier
quoi j'ai fait sur mon petit
c'est le bordel à faire à chaque fois
tous un gambler il rajoute encore un bec
au dernier moment je suis sûr
quand il est sur l'autoroute avec ses
parents dans son enfance mais tu sais
que j'ai déjà parié sur la couleur des
voitures sans blague encore
quelque chose et on a parlé sur la
couleur d'un appartement
[Musique]
pour guéri ouais on va juste terminer ça
alors du coup c'est Kemer contre Magnus
en plus il me force un peu à dire nul à
la caméra j'ai pas envie qu'il perde
avec les Blancs
ok moi c'est bon
[Musique]
vous êtes
entre
[Musique]
c'est bon
alors du coup
ça sent qu'on est en finale comme ça
j'ai pas envie de me faire banane et
tu vois tu dis nul comme comme l'ordi tu
vois tu te fais banane
ok il reste guéri
et vente four rapporte
aux rapportent
moi la prochaine fois on fera en début
stream parce que ça bien un peu le truc
je sais pas si j'aurais eu
moi j'aurais pas mis ça je pense
c'est bon
je t'ai envoyé
moi je te dis ce que j'ai mis sans
regarder encore ton WhatsApp
j'ai mis que Max au DELO allait gagner à
la surprise générale
Carlson va battre mon petit poulain
Kemer Abdou va gagner ça ferait pas mes
affaires mais bon c'est comme ça
j'ai mis que Abdou a les battre Caravana
que sur la
praxe
Guiri a des Badcock
donc en fait en seul en fait tout va se
jouer sur Ding McDo slow et Kemer
Carlson ou taminu les nul et moi j'ai
mis deux gains noirs c'est ça OK
OK
c'est un gars ça a vachement bouger là
ouh là là que se passe-t-il là
ah oui
il a joué cavalier G5 qui était vraiment
un coup à temps à regarder mais dur à
calculer parce que ah je prends gs5 il
faut
envoyer la tour la claquer avec tout
réussi
F6 et maintenant on a beaucoup de coûts
candidats il y a le dame G6 qui est
rigolo mais il y a faux 8 peut-être in
extremis
vous voyez les idées de cavaliers
plongée 5 qui pourraient arriver il y a
peut-être d'un meuf 6 aussi il y a tout
aussi ce qui se regardent et se trouve
nous propose cavalier E5 il y a plein de
coups intéressants en tout cas un sacré
ici une tour et un cavalier guéri et
croyez moi c'est pas le joueur qui va
envoyer la maison
comme ça
a l'air d'être le coup je pense parce
que l'idée c'est que si il bouge la dame
en fait il va nécessaire qui avait
prolongé 5 pour l'instant et qu'elle va
les prendre il y a d'un point mais si je
prends aussi
un musulman plus de pièces c'est ça qui
est fou quoi ouais l'idée c'est un peu
ça quoi mais il peut peut-être claquer
sa dame c'est ça qui faut voir aussi
donc il y a plusieurs parce que tu vois
c'est à ça j'ai plus beaucoup de pièces
après un
on les blancs pour attaquer
[Musique]
deux pièces
parce que
ça se regarde aussi je trouve comme tu
le proposais je menaces cavalier G6 ça
c'est gratuit et surtout à 8
voilà et peut-être d'être trois tours H3
malheureusement surtout aux trois tours
il y a tour des 4 et 34
on a souffrant F3 je pense qu'il va être
joué
parce que le cavalier est beaucoup trop
fort est-ce que sur fou prend F3 je peux
jouer un coup comme dans F5 est-ce que
ça existe ou pas
ça
donc au pire des cas peut-être je veux
ça qui défend ça
moi j'ai deux simplement ce serait bien
alors que sur un projet 2 j'ai qu'une
case de maths
[Musique]
j'ai pas trouvé pour l'instant
non mais je dois acheter
je mets la pression et j'ai je prends F3
de fin de variante si tu veux stuff et
comme ton Caleb 8 est coincé je me dis
que c'est beaucoup
je faisais point F3 à ce moment là
on parlait de ça en fait
je peux y aller directement
j'avais vu ça me semblait dur quand même
cette position
tour des 4
et là
j'étais un petit peu impatient voilà
sans doute
sur G6
noir avec maintenant
genre ça ça
on va finir par la gagner au pire on
fera ça oui il y a toujours
c'est la meilleure options
donc faut prendre 6 et très très dur en
pratique de se défendre avec les lampes
avec les Noirs
je pense qu'il faut manger là parce que
franchement ce qu'avait beaucoup trop
fort quoi
le roi sans doute trop faible ici il y a
une pièce de moins pour pour les blancs
mais le roi est tout nu donc on va aller
chercher quoi
de voir cette partie là
qu'est-ce qui vous donne un petit Abdou
là ce qui va gagner ta partie du coup
maintenant que j'ai parlé sur lui
tous les deux quoi bon ça va il y a que
caméra
j'ai pensé que ça allait gagner pour les
blancs mais
ok c'est en train de s'équilibrer quand
même les pièces restent actives pour les
noirs
malgré une structure très défavorable on
peut peut-être tenir ici avec
les noirs
un petit harcèlement
voilà sauf que je peux faire
est-ce qu'on ferait pas un tour des
stades donc du coup qu'il y en a pas vu
depuis longtemps
on a parlé tout à l'heure dans une autre
position il prend G7 dans 6 pour venir
défendre Etam le dessin
Tam dessin qui vient clouer cette tour
ici
transfert de la dame peut-être aller le
droit aussi sur le coup comme cavalier 8
on viendrait en H5
comme 5 pourrait aussi un jour être
possible
c'est moi moins dans l'esprit mais bon
en même temps ça ouvre aussi ce F2 et le
donc
c'est pas si facile de position pour les
deux joueurs
de temps une pression
mais c'est surtout
c'est surtout Aniche qui devrait faire
la bonne opération
dans ce tournoi
ça c'est certain
en tout cas une position qui a l'air
plutôt cool pour le noir
je crois pas trop à l'attaque pour
l'instant c'est prometteur on voit un
peu ce qui se passe qui est marquage
de grenfeld et on va pas trop ce qui est
positif dans la position de Vincent
Kemer puisque il y a une pièce
d'échanger le centre n'est plus aussi
fort donc très clairement
c'est plutôt plutôt pas mal
je commence à bien aimer les noirs
et la pression au centre avec bien sûr
la prison des 4 qui va avoir lieu
bientôt la part de foot tape sur les
pions moi j'aime bien les noirs
[Musique]
est sain et avec le Centre commence à
voir ce pointer des échanges potentiels
comme fusée 4 ça fait pas plaisir
puisque notre majorité centrale va se
dévaluer petit à petit si on n'arrive
pas à en profiter et jouer dessin
évidemment dans une position comme ça
c'est ouvrir le fou G7 donc c'est pas
évident sachant qu'il t'apprécie
directement sur ces trois donc attention
c'est pas c'est pas clair pas clair
bon est-ce que on prépare une petite
pause stouffe pour
mon chat qui me défonce la porte là
on fait 10 minutes ok
[Musique]
on vous a donné de quoi faire pendant
les postes tout à l'heure j'ai vu
quelqu'un monsieur Nevers qui demandait
des conseils pour bien débuter les
échecs
il faut il faut apprendre évidemment à
calculer à bien respecter les principes
d'ouverture et pour ça on a fait
beaucoup de vidéos avec sauf sur nos
chaînes YouTube respectives donc déjà ça
peut permettre de progresser voilà
Monsieur Nevers mais bien sûr pâte nous
dit il faut faire des tactiques donc
calcul et tactiques c'est vraiment deux
choses qui se bossent conjointement
quand on fait plein de petits diagrammes
et ça on peut en faire facilement seul
alors que les autres sujets du monde est
Chica sont beaucoup plus difficiles à
aborder seul il y a une réponse quand on
fait de la tactique il y a vraiment la
recherche du meilleur coût donc c'est un
très très bon conseil pas de métal donc
c'est c'est très très bien
ici là juste
[Musique]
un plan clair pour les blancs pour
améliorer cette position voilà voilà bon
du coup on part en pause on vous dit à
tout de suite en réservoir 5 minutes de
pause et du coup ben à tout de suite je
vous mets je vais je vais être gentil je
vais je vais essayer de voir une vidéo
qui a une vidéo qui est plutôt sympa
plutôt que de vous mettre la la la scène
que j'avais la dernière fois je vais
essayer la vidéo
la vidéo qui en est je regarde si ça
marche
non la petite innovation technique de
sport
et puis là depuis que le stream
il y avait Arnaud qui attendait la pub
avec grand plaisir il va être exaucé
pourquoi elle marche pas que j'arrive à
la relancer là
j'essaye de mon côté avant de
ah c'est bon
on te dit dans le chat allez à tout de
suite je vous l'envoie à tout de suite
et le
World's YouTube
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour on est désolé
pour cette vidéo qui qui est
sympa on l'a bien vu quand même on l'a
bien vu on l'a bien vu mais j'apprécie
les petites images en noir et blanc
stouf c'est j'ai trouvé ça cool moi
ouais si remercier qui se croiser
parce qu'au final et ben Kemer a joué
des cinq et carton n'a répondu par
fougères donc
voilà donc il a dit ouais je suis nul
mais je propose ça voilà et ben écoute
tu es au moins aussi nul que Kemer donc
c'est plutôt pas mal voilà
par défaut il y avait peut-être pas le
choix aussi c'est-à-dire que il y avait
une pression latente si on faisait pas
des cinq qu'est-ce qu'on faisait mais ça
ça en dit long et même le temps dit long
sur la position de Kemer qui est
vraiment pas reluisante
j'aurais bien aimé
tu vois j'acceptais de jouer contre mon
poulain pour ouais c'est bien c'est beau
pour pas grand chose hein le prono du
jour c'est vrai que la bon la position à
la valeur
sans rentrer vraiment dans l'état
légal quoi mais du coup petit à petit je
pense que 45 comme ça prendre un petit
peu l'avantage en tout cas plus facile à
jouer de son côté en tout cas et ça fait
beaucoup alors que je suis aronyan et
Prague bah ça a fini par faire nul mais
ça on l'attendait depuis un petit moment
donc belle belle partie de Prague qui a
fait 1100 aucun problème avec les Noirs
contre aroniables toujours plaisir de
faire nul sans sans difficulté contre un
joueur de ce niveau-là après peut-être
Caroline n'a pas réussi son meilleur
ouais s'améliore ouverture non non
c'est pas le match qui est évidemment
nous intéresser le plus simple
donc après on avait une partie
intéressante
digne ça a beaucoup évolué c'est ça dès
que ça évolue donc là il y a le roi qui
est toujours tout nu mais il y a plus de
dames alors que c'est pas c'est quoi on
s'est arrêté à Dame des cinq croissant
G7 ah il a finalement tout échangé pour
rentrer dans la finale et continuer à
tout échanger on va avoir sur mon droit
à ça ce qui généralement ces échanges là
qui évident si je me trompe peut-être
peuvent favoriser comme les noirs avec
la paire de fou je sais pas si c'est
vrai tout à fait mais il y a une idée
juste pour un tour recette qui sera pas
facile à apparaître puisque le foie 7
est un peu coincé bizarrement il a pas
de cases ce four à 7 donc on va revenir
sur l'échiquier pour l'instant tant que
j'ai une tour en E5
donc est-ce que les tourne pourront pas
s'activer sur la colonne E dans
l'intervalle bah si sans doute
on prend pour prendre et voir que
j'arrive à faire en tout cas bon pas
simple il y a quand même deux pions pour
la paire de fou
pour les blancs donc c'est difficile à
juger cette position c'est
[Musique]
envie de prendre les Noirs c'était au
fond de moi je
le sentiment
je sais pas
est-ce qu'il faut faire tourner 8 tours
des 7 dans une position comme ça ou tout
re 8 pour échanger une nouvelle fois une
tour
ça va dépendre je pense de son bizarre
mais j'ai du mal à pousser 5 je peux pas
ramener ma fous en fait toi mais fous
sont un peu cadenacées à cause un graphe
à la tour des seins qui contrôlera
toutes les cases de l'échiquier ah c'est
pas facile c'est pas facile
donc
ça va être intéressant en tout cas ça a
fortement évolué là la position
c'est quand même vraiment vraiment
pas simple
de juger une position comme celle-là
en tout cas il faut que les Noirs
réussissent à remettre leur fous en jeu
donc tour 8 dans une position comme ça
pas comme du sens la distance
après l'échange plus de tour et le fait
de plus avoir de tour peut-être que ça
me permettra de pouvoir jouer chez 4 ou
2 pour défendre la roi la roi là poussez
les pions est-ce que la part de fou
toute seule pourra arrêter une tour et
deux pions il y a toujours G8 qui est
intéressant
posé dans le chat qui est clairement
beaucoup de sens qui attaque G2 et sur
la poussée G3 et ben du coup
sur casse blanche ce serait pas bon en
plus
et sur G4 et ben on voit que H5 ne
serait pas possible à cause de temps
donc voilà mais l'idée des blancs sur le
long terme ce serait vraiment d'essayer
de défendre depuis un F2 de jouer G4
si j'arrive à faire G4 moi j'ai 2 rang
G3 F4 je préfère le
mais est-ce que je dois réussir à le
faire c'est pas sûr
apparemment
je vais actualiser la page effectivement
la tour je l'aime beaucoup ici j'ai pas
envie de la bouger
tout recettes et aussi comme idée de
faire tous vos deux qui est intéressant
guide fartour 2 en fait c'est qu'on
défend F2 et grâce à la défense du plan
F2 je crois tranquillement pour venir
manger de quoi vous êtes en finale le
roi en l'active et en plus on pourra
enfin le fait d'activer droit ça va nous
aider aussi à pousser des pions de ce
côté là tu vois qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant avec après ce tour j'ai
visité 4 c'est compliqué parce qu'après
tout
je sais pas comment bon ton recette ça
peut être une menace clairement et puis
en prise tout ça
donc quel intérêt d'avoir provoqué au
final G4 des blancs
sachant qu'on plante de monter le roi je
suis pas sûr donc peut-être pour 8 pour
moi c'est pas un déco candidat qui avait
en tête l'eau
[Musique]
tu nous fais plus McDo slow ben c'est
makut
ça ça peut changer un petit peu ça peut
changer un petit peu
en tout cas oui là c'est un mot un petit
peu difficile pour Max zouglou très
clairement il doit il doit trouver
comment animer ses fous et comment ne
pas subir
les tours les restreintes les tours
blanches
très mauvaise cette histoire
[Musique]
tout recettes et là je te bouffe tout
pour refaire tout rose
pour G8 ok c'est mignon mais ce qui va
pas faire tout revu derrière
mais du coup est-ce que j'ai quatre
c'est quand même un coup vous
amélioration des blancs il me semble un
petit peu étonné enfin si il a joué
qu'il ne joue pas derrière assez vite
son idée
un petit peu un petit peu bizarre ok
donc j'ai 4 jouer par par Ding et d'un
coup je pense que j'aime bien les blancs
non mais en fait digne il va peut-être
réussir à gagner finalement
parce que moi j'avais mis max doudou
alors que je l'avais mis en dernier de
mon classement mais je suis sur cette
partie ça a l'air intéressant ce qu'il a
joué qu'est-ce qu'il aurait dû jouer du
coup je souffre où il a perdu l'avantage
dans ce E5 là parce que
l'ordi avait l'air préférer les noirs et
maintenant ils préfèrent les blancs et
ce qu'il fallait jouer un coup comme D5
qui est pas instinctif avec la paire de
fou
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait jouer dans cette
structure c'est dans ma question parce
qu'il a tiqué sur cavalier prend 5
mais D5 c'est pas instinctif quand même
si c'est ça c'est pas instinctif
la position mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas un coup qui est très très
standard ça va bizarre c'est vraiment
j'ai du mal à comprendre enfin je
comprends Ding donc du coup comme il a
les tours bah il essaie d'ouvrir la
position enfin les colonnes ça ouvre
quand même la paire de fou et là j'ai
l'impression que d'un petit avantage
noir on est passé à petit avantage blanc
et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé quoi
bah qu'est-ce qu'on devait jouer parce
que c'est pas si facile mine de rien
c'est
naturel ce qu'il a fait de tout échanger
en E5
il se fait il se fait gronder par
l'ordinateur c'est logique de vouloir de
vouloir en fait ouvrir les colonnes pour
les tours quoi mais après puis en B4
est-ce que ici il y a pas ah oui non
j'ai pensé à fousser Sphinx
j'ai pensé au début je voulais essayer
d'activer mon fou mais il y a toujours
P4
en fait et sur eux aussi on s'en fout il
fait ça quoi mais ok pas évident mais en
fait les compréhensible parce que Ben
les tours seront actifs dans les
colonnes ouvertes et après ça ça ben je
ralentis un peu quand même ton attaque
pendant ce temps-là je peux ouvrir la
mienne et préparer un peu plus mais
clairement c'est c'est dur à anticiper
tout ça quoi
l'avantage maintenant est au blanc quoi
donc avoir pas évident il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de mouvements alors on peut
aller voir un peu ce qui se passe on a
on a guéri regarde ce qui se passe chez
Guiri
[Musique]
de résister et l'idée que c'est que bon
bah il contrôle la case 7 là j'aurais
peut-être une fois H7
possible
[Musique]
c'est ce que je me posais comme question
mais sinon
j'aimais quand même qui qui marche
quasiment pas j'ai une cam sur
sur gamer
j'ai une cam sur
[Musique]
sur la partie de Ding contre parram j'ai
une cam sur guéri mais le reste rien ne
marche je vais essayer je vais réessayer
pendant que
guérir réellement
ça a l'air vraiment d'avoir une bonne
tête mais si le joue pas à tempo c'est
qu'il a ses raisons
tu reprends des cartes de F3 ça a l'air
dans ma chambre
tout ça j'essaie de te demander les
cames pour essayer de te rouler tu vois
à ce moment-là faire une menace la
petite
pour essayer de gagner l'analyse vous
savez on aime ça et c'est de rouler ton
collègue dans les complications paiera
surveiller le NAS tactique et régler la
technique c'est dur
c'est dur donc bah écoutez on va on va
faire comme ça
il cherche donc il a l'air d'avoir un
petit problème
mais du coup il a peur de quoi sur son
temps 4 peut-être que du coup le coup
sera pas pour prendre des cartes
peut-être qu'il va jouer un coup de
développement
où ça peut être peut-être se laisser
se laisser prendre dans mes fuites
plutôt d'en prendre 4 tours des cas d'un
F3 et peut-être G4
mais ça a l'air il est peut-être en
train de calculer les conséquences de
Damel fuite c'est ce qu'on est vraiment
mat c'est pas sûr s'ils soufflent
donc on va regarder Kevin nous propose
c'est ça
qui dit déjà il a pas le problème du
voisin qui fait ses travaux en plus
voilà c'est en parlant de de
pas mal Néandertal j'ai pas le voisin
mais j'ai mon chat
[Musique]
c'est pas possible
et donc là je le donne cette peluche
c'est la petite peluche toute petite un
petit ours et quand elle a quand elle a
la peluche elle est elle pleure elle
pleure de joie et elle joue avec c'est
trop marrant
elle pleure de joie
avec le sa peluche moi tranquille et
elle joue avec
donc du coup tu disais j'ai cap
peut-être qui empêche du coup le match
ici
et après
ça fait très peur par exemple
je vais jouer au washi
et tu vas simplement peut-être jouer G3
à un moment voir
[Musique]
est possible
mais bon a priori ça a l'air quand même
d'aller en plus non seulement j'ai le
matériel d'avance mais en plus ce qui se
passe c'est que tu as vraiment du mal à
sortir telle pièce en fait alors comment
les noirs peuvent résister sur dame F3
est-ce qu'il y a une résistance possible
parce que visiblement c'est pas G4
donc
surprend d'un F3
[Musique]
que tout à l'heure on a déjà vu
mais est-ce que ce serait pas tout
simplement gagnant et je sais pas mais
Aniche il a dû voir quelque chose qui le
gène mais j'arrive pas à
salut Trucy
tu vois ici
pour
je sais mais je pense que ça vient au
même on va venir là
c'est problématique développer le
cavalier C6 dans l'idée c'est excellence
que tu proposes mais tes maths donc
forcée
on n'a pas trouvé ce qui le gène
h
et
la case fuite bon la colonnache et la
kazaki
[Musique]
se passe donc faire attention vraiment
être sûr de soi quand on joue un tel
point donc ces quatre c'est la partie a
eu pris en Russie histoire coin aussi et
quand un scène qui a qui a ici une une
pression extraordinaire
il y a ça qui se pression et voilà
il y aura des yeux de cavaliers A4 pour
soit rebondir en C5 soit mettre une
pression en C3
on a demandé ça a l'air d'être
extrêmement difficile donc la fouleuse
me semble logique
je prends là
je reprends et je me lasse fouder trois
enfin tu vois tu imagines le truc ça
aurait été du coup horrible voilà
et là on peut commencer à penser à
cavalier A4 peut-être
juste pour menacer
tout il y a cavalier Descartes à tout
moment et du coup cavalier A4 permet
d'avoir des C3 donc là tu seras obligé
de donner ton fou
enfin peut-être pas mais si ce serait
embêtant alors que dans cavalier 4 quand
tu donnes ton foot à C3 derrière et je
crois que ça ça roule ça roule bien donc
que Kevin ne veut nous expliquer c'est
que bon là il y a une fourchette du coup
je peux des fois sacrifier le fou
sur le cavalier pour essayer de de
d'empêcher tout ça et mettre la pression
mais aussi pour bloquer le coup ici
c'est trois ça marchera pas mais du coup
ce qu'il veut nous dire c'est qu'à la
place ça c'est ce qu'elle va le 4 par
celle-là j'aurais peut-être du C3 qui
attaque le fou et je gagne un peu un
temps dessus il y a toujours la présence
sur le sur le sur le 4 le pion qui
pouvait s'avancer et du coup le purge 3
qui avance donc intéressant en tout cas
donc en tout cas il y a eu il faut
prendre cavalier prend
il y a plusieurs coups intéressants
l'ordi il a l'air de vouloir encore plus
de la position parce qu'il dit que c'est
énorme ici ma avantage donc là il y a
l'histoire de la menace de cahier des
quatre donc
[Musique]
il faut juste le prévenir j'ai pensé à
damacat mais on aurait le problème d'en
prendre cavalier prendre
il y aurait le problème sur B5
comment on fait pour prévenir tout cela
que vous voyez la jauge qui est en
faveur très très largement de noir on a
cette indice qui qu'on peut pas ignorer
on nous a dit de mettre la jauge donc on
met la jauge
[Musique]
je pense qu'il y a un coup de conclusion
qu'on n'arrive pas à trouver stouf et à
m'énerve ou alors Cavalia 4 cavalier des
4 tours
et je te
et c'est difficile quoi c'est embêtant
pour madame
mais on est dans les cordes ici avec les
Blancs on est vraiment que penses-tu
d'un coup comme dans
5 je prends 4 et un peu tout qui
s'écroule
mais bon tu as pas forcément envie de
donner la structure
[Musique]
donner le Fougerat c'est quand même
dommage
il a joué
tu étais en train d'en parler
[Rires]
en fait là il veut dans ma Caf
et après j'ai du C3
en plus échanger par rapport à ce qu'on
a vu il veut en plus échanger les dames
pour avoir une finale où le pion c'est
va débouler
encore une fois tu vois on en parle en
début de stream déjà
et puis quand ça ne pense que c'est du
chaud froid ouais il sait faire des
petits coups des petits coups posés
aussi il met la pression et par moment
petit coup calme parce qu'il a déjà mis
son adversaire en grande difficulté et
en maintenant juste la position ça
devrait s'écrouler maintenant il a 30
minutes il est en train de faire une
grosse partie
[Musique]
une ressource qu'on n'avait pas
forcément vu tout bah ils sont dans le
G4 tu vois ce qu'on avait dit et c'est
pas reluisant je pense que Guéry
en fait la première variante mais qu'on
voit c'est vite je peux vous montrer
donc c'est dans cette position mais
c'est vrai que nous ce qui change en
fait c'est qu'on a les Vals et ça
pourrit tout parce que on sera en partie
à regarder dans mes fuites on verrait
que c'est gagnant sans doute mais on a
envie de tout maîtriser quand on est en
partie longue et le roi en Hachette il
est à la fois en grande difficulté mais
on a pas forcément match forcer
c'est la partie de la cuisine
il a joué encore
qu'il a joué à Nice
va être plutôt assez en tout cas il
prend bien son temps parce que
c'est gagnant mais
le roi étant HS
c'est mignon en tout cas Triboulet de
chaises
ouais c'est pas mal aussi pas mal aussi
ça
que là-bas
une batterie assez standard mais en même
temps cette menace serait très très
forte
échec et mats terminado
c'est bien hein
c'est la même
tout à fait mon gré tu as bien raison de
dire voilà c'est bon on sent qu'il va
quand même gagner à Nice
en jouant à peu près n'importe quel coup
ici mais oui il est obligé de il est pas
en blitz il faut qu'il assure son gain
dans cette position écrasante
que le roi de l'adversaire est
complètement coincé cavalier tour son
coincé donc c'est la catastrophe malgré
l'avantage matériel
ah bah ils sont très précis à ce niveau
ça c'est clair elles ont pas le choix
à ce niveau-là
les joueurs dans cette position comme ça
là
il parle plus quoi c'est fini ils ont
fait leur classe c'est-à-dire qu'avant
ils ont eu des problèmes pour arriver au
niveau de 2007 2008
ils ont tout pris aux échecs en fait ils
étaient très doués certes mais les
échecs ça ne rate pas et en un coup tu
peux balancer un avantage un avantage
que tu penses à qui durablement
finalement il peut s'évaporer assez vite
donc de leurs expériences des fois des
mauvaises expériences il retire
énormément de choses et ils sont plus à
voir mais il faut F5 ou C2 c'est
extrêmement joli
c'est le plus simple et je pense c'est
ce qui va
le fou B6 protège la tour des cartes
York je pense que tu parles de ça
et je sais pas si c'était au bon moment
mais Google en difficulté effectivement
Pat
et tu vois que on va aller voir
rapidement si tu veux il a réussi à
jouer tour des sets
l'idée c'est que il a fait G4 enfin il a
fait donc j'ai 8 pour forcer chez 4 et
après tout il va me jeton D7
et maintenant on se dit que bon les les
blancs sont actifs avec leur tour tout
ça les deux fous sont quand même assez
forts voyez que le roi il a un petit peu
un problème et que si par exemple là il
y a une idée qui est intéressante c'est
tout
c'est tout à F5 et quand le roi bouge en
fait ce serait de faire par exemple ton
Rossi essaie d'aller manger des pions et
en fait maintenant avec ma paire de fou
et l'autre tour vous voyez je peux
facilement en arrivant en dessous par
exemple juste un exemple simple échec
voilà et là il y a des échecs ici avec
mon fou et c'est pas simple le roi blanc
peut monter pour essayer de mater ça
peut être très chaud
ça peut ça peut être chaud
mais en tout cas intéressant
je sais pas si c'est possible de jouer
un petit C5 bien sûr pour essayer de
faire
donc pas très malin
tu fais l'inverse
[Musique]
avec toi
il y aura peut-être refoulé vite mais
bon l'idée est là mais ok assez 5 jouets
la partie il y a de l'idée
c'est 5 donc là il empêche tout ça et
puis maintenant il va jouer fou B8 on
peut jouer F4 peut-être pour fermer
cette diago et ah non il aurait tour des
deux c'est bien je pense un souffle au
final et ben le le roi il est quand même
sous pression parce que après F4 tu vois
et ben le roi il est hyper ouvert en
fait
il y a quand même une grosse faute de de
Paran MacDo de l'eau c'était pour G8
parce qu'il a accéléré la poussée
blanche elle est le roi c'est favorise
les blancs à ce moment-là donc il a
accéléré ça mais d'un autre côté
on change les quatre et ben il a ouvert
en fait le foot 15 branches du coup
peut-être qu'il pensait que le fait de
faire jaquette avec les Blancs ben ça me
permettrait au noir de d'avoir
suffisamment de jeu mais je crois sauf
que jusqu'au 23e coup max de l'eau a
fait une partie assez extraordinaire
contre dingly Rennes et il s'est
complètement trompé sur l'évaluation de
E5 avec l'histoire de son fou coincé il
s'est retrouvé moins bien qui se pensait
mieux et là il a commencé à imploser
avec tour G8 qui était vraiment pas un
bon coup vraisemblablement et maintenant
on voit que Ding va s'évertuer à lui
faire du mal
parce qu'il veut gagner digne je pense
que il a eu peur dans cette partie mais
maintenant il sait qu'il est qu'il est
meilleur
re-salut araignes
alors du coup
donc guéri bon c'est une question de
temps Carson
qu'on avait prévu tout à l'heure il est
pas inquiet en fait très belle maîtrise
comme d'habitude de Carlson toujours les
pièces qui sont vraiment en harmonie tu
as toutes les pièces noires
il va travailler tranquillement cette
position il est pas pressé
qu'avait la 4 a été joué
en train de la voir de faire mal que
c'est 6 donc qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
en fait
une idée parce que là on va bouger la
dame on va la mettre par là
en dessin qui sera une amélioration pour
lui beau petit cavalier ici je regardais
dame C7 à griller cavaliers B6 pour te
dégager mais il y a peut-être pas besoin
de ça j'ai joué simple
de dame E5 dame C7
et cavalier C5 aussi beaucoup de
manœuvres
ça va ça va le faire pour Carsen c'est
une position difficile alors rapidement
un contre caravane donc toujours
égaliser un petit peu
et cette finale là elle est pas parce
que
alors la structure de carwana est
dégueuse qui tout à l'heure il avait une
des pions faibles un peu partout sauf on
peut quand même dire que il a réussi à
liquider car Wana pour se rendre la
défense plus facile maintenant toutes
ces faiblesses sont sur la même l donc
c'est plus facile à tenir bon cependant
cette position a l'air difficile donc
cavalier 7 c'est le seul coup pour
rentrer dans la finale de tour
et
cette position là elle fait elle est pas
très réjouissante quand même
j'ai l'impression que je peux mettre
comme ça
c'est pas facile de passer quand même en
fait c'est ça la conception Kawana c'est
très impressionnant
c'est joli ça
c'est beau
en tout cas en tout cas ça va être
intéressant de voir si il arrive à la
tenir parce que même l'ordinateur il dit
plein de choses mais après il faut en
pratique il faut
faut faire beaucoup et
donc avoir avant avoir ce qui se passe
on n'a pas beaucoup vu la partie de de
la partie
[Musique]
on va venir un peu folle on s'est arrêté
à 5 tout à l'heure il y a eu quasi coup
de jouer donc tourner on avait dit que
ce pion il allait être être faible sur
le long terme oui on sentait pas du tout
Erika easy très frais dans cette
position parce qu'il avait les
faiblesses structurelles les pièces un
peu bizarroïdes
donc on voyait vraiment à Wesley saut
dominateur et réghaïsi à compliquer la
sauce dans cette position avec G5
tout ça le roi qui arrive pas à se
mettre à l'abri donc après je vais 5 il
veut dynamique chasser les pièces
s'activer tu vois c'est un taxe qui fait
complètement
dame 5 il tient d'un pion le roi sur
case noire donc c'est logique sur la
couleur inverse donc dame 5
donc toujours un central quand même
réaction centrale centrale bon c'est
logique le roi noir est au centre
et donc on veut on veut tout casser
c'est chaud hein
à tout moment
mais il y a des pions prend des cartes
attaque Vadam
c'est vrai que là aujourd'hui d'avoir on
va avoir de
beaucoup je pense de
moi je vois déjà Ding peut-être gagner
je vois aussi d'Iri gagner tu vois qu'un
scène gagner peut-être à tout gagner
mais c'est un peu moins sûrs
[Musique]
donc
bonnes
complètement mais en tout cas on va voir
on va voir
faut que ça revenu il me dit ça va ça va
Kevin c'est pas encore fait commence pas
à me chambrer
et oui et oui je suis assez content moi
je suis stouf je pense que il va y avoir
beaucoup de résultats décisifs la prise
de risque payante prise de risque
payante et Aniche est-ce qu'il est en
train de finir notre ami gokesh
je pense que c'est la cagoule vraiment
je pense qu'il va je suis mais
je vais voir s'il a tout à l'heure
il a pas joué encore
[Musique]
avec l'arrivée des coûts sur le serveur
donc fois F5 sur G6 on a dame échec avec
la prise de pions
[Musique]
que c'est quand même peut-être très joli
le coup le
plus facile
et après tout a l'air bien mais cette
fou c'est de c'est le coup le plus
facile je pense pour gagner pour
[Musique]
pour fuir vers F8
ça paraît c'est pas ambitieux mais G6
et on rejouera ensuite dame F6 roi G8
dame ranger 6 on va essayer de fuir de
l'autre côté peut-être
voilà tu peux justement faire ton G3 ou
ton H4
ou encore dans 6 bien sûr on a le temps
de manger mais bon je fais des coups
comme ça il a le temps peut-être de
sortir
il y aura toujours dame F6 et damashe8
gagne la tour à 8 quoi c'est ça qui est
dur
et c'est vrai qu'ici je peux faire G3
peut-être ah bah non j'ai mon fond en
l'air oui j'ai mon fond en l'air c'est
pour ça que j'avais pris sur échec voilà
je joue celle là et je joue un petit H4
ou un petit G3
et ça va le faire tout seul je pense
mais c'est pas impossible qu'on insiste
à cela puisque Google je dois avoir qui
les perdant dans les deux cas il est en
train de regarder peut-être qu'elle est
la vente qui tient le mieux qui est la
plus difficile pour Aniche à trouver
sachant qu'il sait que normalement il
devrait perdre
comme ça on va on va rechercher la
variante la plus compliquée
pour gagner en pratique un pour
l'adversaire exactement
et d'ailleurs on voit que digne
Charleroi le Racing est parti en H4
comment on avait dit il a joué là il a
joué la VaR en dessous mais je suis
désolé pour toi
c'est logique de monter le roi il va
nous servir comme pièce d'attaque il
faut pas se faire mater évidemment son
propre roi mais il y a pas de raison si
on est attentif dans cette position il
va pousser les pions et des deux tours
tout réussi f435 ça va être ça va être
la totale
non ça a l'air ça aurait de plus en plus
gagnant pour pour Ding le magicien quoi
le magicien il y a quelques couches je
n'ai pas cher de sa peau
un peu de réussite aussi la poser les
bons problèmes pratiques évidemment donc
il a aussi
amené cette réussite néanmoins Maxou de
l'eau qui avait fait une grosse partie
c'est quand même un peu emmêlé les
crayons
et maintenant il peut plus rien faire et
il a perdu pied en fait McDo de loin on
le voyait confiant c'est plus le cas
et il me semble cap d'où ça torof a bien
choisi la finale roi tour 4 contre roi
tour 3 avec des faiblesses
et je crois que c'est bon
ça va être la finale la forteresse
forteresse avec les pions cassés
la structure cassée tandis que
un coup de plus ou pas stuff
il y a eu droit
je pense qu'on va assister
à un abandon
beaucoup beaucoup de menaces c'est même
pas quoi jouer il y a un Mango cache a
vu qui était perdant dans tous les
variantes et attente
celle-ci parce que pousser deux c'était
un coup légèrement difficile à trouver
de parer ce mode de couloir
alors qu'on pouvait jouer des petits
coups de pions mais on rappelle un dame
F5 en plus de damashe8 maintenant menace
très fort l'adversaire
là ça va être abandon je pense parce que
franchement Google il a pas de il a pas
de coup il peut pas bouger la tour
au moins la tour noir
donc ça ça bouge pas le fou Ben et des
fois la tour
enfin elle a pas de coup à faire
cette position elle est juste juste en
même temps débile pour essayer de sortir
des pièces
je pense qu'il va faire mal
et pour défendre le match il faut venir
ici bon
[Musique]
on peut ramener le roi de plus en plus
près de nous j'ai trois
et là ça va plus du tout dame 5 par
exemple
et surtout prends F2 il y a roi F1 tout
simplement
la petite fin de partie j'ai ma mat ici
c'est trop dur
trop trop dur par exemple voilà des
jolies choses qui pourraient se produire
sur l'échiquier en tout cas
partie quand même
à sens unique
isolé magistralement joué côté
Aniche guéri
alors on devrait voir victoire d'anis
guéri comme tu l'as dit victoire de
dingly Rain victoire de Carlsen nul je
pense qu'à Juana Abdou
et
qui va devoir encore être
je vois bien caroanna qui a fait ce
choix délibéré
faire nul
après évidemment à titre perso j'aurais
eu cette position avec les noirs
bien sûr sans évaluation je serais dire
ça doit perdre ce parce que si vous
voulez on connaît par cœur cette
position avec stouf le 3 contre 4 avec
les pions F7 G7 H6 c'est très connu ça
fait nul
assez facilement mais ce 3 contrecarlat
c'est pas le 3
standards côté noir les trois pions là
c'est une structure qui est bizarre mais
force cette constater que le roi G6 ça
c'est top parfait et on peut pas
progresser avec les Blancs facilement
parce que tu vois bon après imagine
qu'elle a un niveau les finales
ils connaissent bien tu vois
mais cette finale un peu atypique
et du coup on trouve ça beau parce que
on va dire que la photo est tellement
mais ouais la photo est paraît tellement
immonde que cette conception tienne
c'est ça en devient beau voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on aime les échecs
parce que ça brise on connaît les règles
générales mais elles sont souvent
régulièrement brisées par le haut niveau
ils prennent quelques largesses et c'est
ce qu'on aime
surtout qu'on comprend ce qui va le
faire
qui est mort il a réussi maintenant
Caval en dessin
tu vois
très simple il me l'aimait les pièces
sur les meilleurs cases il va pouvoir
bientôt mettre un gros cavalier des
trois
qui est
pas un coup encore
l'idée ça aurait été de pouvoir se
débarrasser de défenseur du cavaliers
pour pouvoir en fait
d'un coup le capturer quoi mais là je
pensais à cavalier
prend ces trois elle doit pas être
génial
j'ai que les meilleures pièces c'est
très dur tu as dans cette partie
ils m'ont répété
parce qu'en fait j'ai une grosse
compréhension
ça peut être pas mal aussi
non ok c'est intéressant clairement mais
c'est peut-être pas forcément
[Musique]
l'idéal tu as une position avec avantage
pourquoi ça crée du matériel donc
la cabane du cavalier 7 on est pas
vraiment sûr de vouloir échanger les
pièces même si ça reste quand même
intéressant
je prends là on a échangé des pièces de
finale vous voyez tout l'avantage pour
Magnus c'est ce qui peut le faire
réfléchir et perdre un peu de temps
l'organisme guéris ça a signé la feuille
j'ai l'impression c'est tout
qui est très content donc
le résultat est assez clair
Giri qui a gagné
là on attendait l'abandon
après tous ces deux
donc oui 1 0 1 0 pour guérir qui gagne
cette partie du coup
donc on va changer un petit peu de
partie je vais voir si j'ai une petite
caméra à vous montrer pour les joueurs
j'ai une caméra possible
j'ai Ding je vais vous montrer la je
pense
alors que faut que ça Anonymous tu
propose n'hésitez pas à contacter
souffre du coaching de qualité jouer aux
hasard ça peut être pas mal aussi voilà
il a bien aimé ta masterclass là il nous
suit bien fonctionné au hasard venez
chez nous vous aurez des coups au hasard
aussi
très bon fonctionnement
très présent
et des fois et moi on m'a toujours dit
que quand je jouais à des jeux un peu de
hasard m'a toujours dit que j'avais
beaucoup de chance et
du coup bah écoutez
[Musique]
ça applique à merveille bon dur pour
pour gooche ce démarrage quand même
c'est pas facile Google qui fait zéro
sur deux dans ce tournoi il a eu il a
une poignée blanc hier une fois les
Noirs aujourd'hui oh il a pas vu le
plastique
il faut le tenir
mais bon
je pense qu'il va perdre cette partie
avant le contrôle de temps parce que là
ça s'effrite complètement on n'a plus
rien à faire les deux fous ne peuvent
pas sortir
[Musique]
en fait de base hyperactive quand on
voyait le roi ici avec le pion G4 jouets
on avait l'impression que que le roi
était en raison en fait mais dès que les
Noirs ont permis au roi blanc de
s'échapper ben les fous sont
là
plus important quand même passé
maintenant après la prise c'est ce qu'il
a fait
ce qui voulait peut-être faire aussi au
final c'était avoir le flou qui puisse
un jour venir en F7 tu vois pour
empêcher le roi H5 et la prise du curage
complètement c'est maintenant tour 3
pions contre cette paire de fou
avec
des pions qui commencent à prendre de la
valeur
il essaie quand même d'embrouiller un
petit peu mais c'est pas suffisant
[Musique]
c'est pas le
c'est pas un débile
mais
jings c'est vraiment un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde
sans conteste
là il est à 28 11 et bah c'est le numéro
2 c'est le seul joueur avec Carlsen à
avoir actuellement plus de 2800
d'avoir la chance de jouer pour le titre
le titre de champion du monde
prochainement on prenait pas
des pronostics des choses que tu
ça va ça va être hyper dur parce que
même n'est pas alors il a complètement
craqué pendant le match contre Carlson
mais il avait montré un très bon niveau
de jeu pendant un mois avant de
complètement craquer et ça fait quand
même deux fois que il est
gagnant du tournoi des candidats qui est
quand même un tournoi extrêmement fort
donc
clairement c'est un match pour moi un
défi
le score j'en sais rien mais par contre
ce qui est pour moi
je pense que
[Musique]
que Ding va gagner
pour moi c'est un joueur d'échec qui est
bien meilleur
en terme de qualité de joueurs c'est bon
et mon avis alors tu vois 45 il a je
sais pas alors peut-être qu'il a pas
fait exprès peut-être qu'il a fait comme
ça
royale sans voir
je décompense et tu vois donc encore une
fois moi je l'avais proposé sans voir la
fourchette mais vous voyez comme quoi
encore une fois ça fait plusieurs fois
je le Croatie tout à l'heure de 45 le
coup de cavalier prend un 4 en fait si
vous regardez les commentaires vous avez
l'impression que ça fait bien aligné
donc mais en fait j'ai beaucoup de
chance si tu réfléchis pas je trouve que
tu joues comme Carlsen mais c'est clair
il faut que tu réfléchisses beaucoup
moins en fait si vous voulez être
coacher c'est facile ne réfléchissez pas
je vous découvre au hasard des coups qui
vous semblent bons et la nuit vers le
centre vers le centre quand même
globalement
toujours à peu près
[Musique]
faites des menaces aussi ça ça peut pas
être mauvais
[Musique]
il est en train de dire à chaque fois et
plus convaincu dans le chat des conseils
avec moi mais bon
mais non mais vous voyez les karaté à
chaque coup il lance un dé et puis
il affiche un petit peu l'endroit dans
la zone quelle il doit jouer et puis
comme ça qu'il joue quoi et il joue très
très bien
compris il envoie une belle majorité
trois contraints il va créer c'est
devenir pousser un genre à 4 B3
[Musique]
monstrueux pour ceux qui aiment le rugby
c'est le pack néo-zélandais le qui est
en action voilà les All Blacks et ça va
faire très très mal c'est la médaille
qui avance et on pourra rien faire avec
les Blancs on a beau avoir des tours
qu'est-ce qu'on va en faire on peut pas
mettre de menaces concrètes en place et
souffre nous parle du
A4 B3 que l'on va voir arriver
inexorablement
et je prendrai en fait c'est pareil
enfin tu as plus de pièces tes tours ça
sert à rien
moi je peux
en vente je vois au hasard sur la
plateforme de cours en ligne ça c'est
stouf pour sa nouvelle plateforme dès
qu'il la mettra en place non mais je
vais rester un livre
comment jouer au hasard
en fait le livre il va être simple une
page c'est le D sur le 1 je le descends
le jeu une petite vidéo YouTube sur
comment jouer au hasard ça serait pas
mal et je pense qu'il y a matière
[Musique]
si tu veux on se commande
et voilà comment garder joue et gagne au
hasard c'est
[Musique]
et si de nous dit bah ouais le fou de la
grande Feld bah il est en pleine action
et salut à toi Gaïa et oui peut-être que
je vais préférer le livre de stouffe sur
le joue au hasard parce qu'il m'a appris
pas mal de choses je trouve du coup sur
ce sujet-là j'espère que dans mes
prochaines compétitions j'aurai
l'occasion de le mettre en application
et de la bonne manière c'est à dire pas
faire n'importe quoi avec ce petit
conseil
et du coup ben il faut jouer au hasard
mais mais
maintenant au hasard tu vois en fait
et il y a failli voudrait que tu fasses
une petite série il y aurait commenté
jouer au hasard ensuite comment gagner
au hasard
mais il y a beaucoup de hasard le hasard
c'est c'est le hasard et
il peut y avoir donc sans blague mais il
peut y avoir des fois de la chance aux
échecs dans des varanes qu'on a mal
calculé mais il se trouve que bien sûr
en fait c'est hyper bien joué moi ça
m'arrive des fois ça j'ai pas besoin
d'expliquer je crois que vous savez déjà
mais ça m'est déjà arrivé plus d'une
fois d'avoir des positions enfin de
jouer à un coup et après l'avoir
merde le blender ça perd direct et après
je regarde je calcule ouf j'ai ça et
juste après avoir joué je me rends
compte que j'ai que j'ai fait des gros
trucs ça ça m'arrive assez régulièrement
quand même ouais bien sûr on a les
pièces bien placées tout ça je dirais
que les bons joueurs en plus de chance
que les joueurs amateurs parce que leur
pièce sont bien placées aussi donc du
coup notre récupèrent un petit peu c'est
dans les boîtes
généralement il y a moins de tactique
toi tes pièces sont défendues entre
elles tout ça tu es moins propice à
Blender des pièces quoi
qui prennent exemple
[Musique]
il faut la provoquer on est maintenant
assez convaincu que Carlsen va battre
Vincent Kmer il va falloir qu'il
confirme mais le numéro 1 mondial nous
habitué à un moment en cadence lente à
être très propre
digne et Max Zodio c'était c'était très
très mal parti pour
au max au DELO enfin en tout cas c'était
très compliqué pour lui avec défendre
moi j'avais mis bien mcdoslo je suis
assez content parce que faut que dingue
maintenant parce que quoi
j'avais mis 45 contre mon chouchou bah
tu regardes ton chou regarde
en partie c'était un coup brillant alors
c'était pas fait exprès tu vois tu vois
et ben c'est comme ça qu'il faut
exactement comme ça ça c'est la classe
en vrai quand tu fais un super coup ça
fait exprès c'est génial enfin moi
j'adore quoi tu vois comme ça m'est déjà
arrivé de mater sans faire exprès
peut-être tu fais du Bullet il te reste
0,3 secondes et tu mates
exprès et comme l'autre fois ça m'est
arrivé j'ai joué c'était contre côté nuk
je contre elle c'était un tournoi sur
tfcom ça devait être le l'Arena Kings et
je l'ai maté à la dernière seconde et
non non c'est pas maté excuse-moi on a
répété trois fois l'imposition à la
dernière seconde il me restait 0,01
comme ça et en fait on a répété mais si
tu veux on a fait deux fois la
répétition à un moment donné après j'ai
plein d'autres coups et à un moment
donné on a fait un coup qui a un
transposé dans les deux positions qu'on
avait fait avant mais genre dit quoi
avant
et le pire c'est que moi cette position
et enfin j'étais persuadé que j'avais
que j'avais perdu autant parce qu'elle
m'avait flingue et donc bah je continue
et tout et le lendemain je me suis rendu
compte que le lendemain parce que je
cherchais la partie pour la montrer et
j'ai fait nul et j'avais pas compris que
j'avais fait nul en fait
c'était au hasard
mais
le hasard l'échec c'est important
[Musique]
moins il y a de hasard quand même et les
échecs en cas d'enceinte permettent
d'essayer de jouer pour la vérité
mais c'est pas si facile que ça à faire
on a dit qu'il y avait la pendule qu'il
fallait jouer pratique etc donc c'est
pas si simple mais dites ça maintenant
aux échecs je joue pour trouver la
vérité c'est assez classe faut le dire
comme ça oui
[Rires]
moi quand je commence à partir
du couloir et puis ça peut monter mener
une pseudo-attaque mais ok
pour essayer de se sortir un petit peu
de cette position en termes et essayer
d'amener un peu de folie mais bon pas
grand chose quand même pas grand pas
grande menace
est-ce que
l'eau a réussi à jouer un coup depuis
tout reprend un 6 ou il est toujours
pointé non non je crois qu'il est coin
il est pas content
s'il évolue beaucoup il avance un petit
peu mais il va devoir mettre des
échanges de pions en place pour passer
et du coup ça devrait faire une
liquidation est-ce qu'on peut voir
rapidement stouf cette échiquier où on a
un beau petit cas de contre 3
juste
la position véritablement
toujours très difficile de vous indiquer
des plans
alors du coup pardon je voulais mettre
la partie de je voulais vous mettre à
Botox il y a 4 contre 3 du coup
l'ordinateur qui gagne 0-0 l'ordinateur
parce qu'à chaque fois on va échanger
les pions et ça favorise le défenseur
parce que pour avancer dans cette
position pas faire vraiment beaucoup de
menaces pour pour avancer dans la
production il va falloir un moment donné
échanger les pions et échanger les pions
bah du coup ma structure elle sera plus
aussi moche qu'elle est maintenant en
fait ça surtout que dégueulasse et ben
c'est qu'une illusion au final parce que
tout final tout tout dépend
en plus
attaquer ben je pourrais toujours venir
défendre qu'il en fait
dans la partie de
de dingeren
F4 F2 F4 oui sur sur échec Roland il
revient je peux jouer F4 et me sortir
des déchets
c'est un concept on vous a appris
peut-être maintenant quelques années
peut-être
Cyril attention
mais on va progresser là je sais pas il
va bouger la tour c'est le pion
gagne la tour encore que ouais il y a le
fou des 5 en l'air donc c'est même pas
ouais
c'est pas la bonne case non mais là j'ai
pas une femme mais peut-être même pas
non ça il y aura ça mais j'ai pas de 4
pour l'instant je peux manger ici manger
ici jouer 4 voilà et puis
peut-être un petit G5 on va réussir à
passer
ça devrait
progresser il n'y a pas de raison alors
chaud hyper intense il s'est passé plein
de choses là
et au final on a un gazé qui se bat
hypervient qui arrive
sous pression
dans la prise dans la position tu vois
moi ça me faisait peur oui c'est vrai et
il y a eu ça ça crise et tout F2 et en
fait au final
[Musique]
l'impression que les noirs sont mal mais
en fait ils arrivent vraiment à jouer
actif ce qui fait que ça empêche
l'adversaire de jouer tu vois que la
dame en D4 qui est quand même contre
toutes les cases noires
D1 et chaque il y a du coup on se sort
des des problématiques au niveau du roi
donc il a mangé depuis un et il revient
et tiens et calcul très très bien les
joueurs pour pas se faire planter dans
ces positions là
vraiment je peux gagner derrière parce
que si je prends le pion pour défendre
pas simple avoir parce que sur un truc
comme ça je peux toujours faire pour
réussir du roi des 6 je crois que tu es
obligé de faire ça d'ailleurs parce que
sinon il y a des tours à 8 ce qui
arrivaient donc c'est très bien joué ce
tour c'est un souffle
au pire des cas il y a toujours à 8 mais
il y a même aussi de Tours C5
il revient quoi donc mais ce pion il est
pas dépendable mais je me dis que si je
le perds je pourrais venir après manger
ici
ça bug des fois
et cinq tours
et j'attaque là et sur la défense ici
roi des 6
et sur 3D 4
si je bouffe bouffe bouffe voilà
ouais puis peut-être que je peux mettre
un petit un petit F4 ici dans cette
position pour
moi j'étais pas fan de 5 en fait parce
que j'ai l'impression que tu cherches un
petit peu
le temps en fait dans cette position
avant de commencer par liquider je
préfère
être plus échanger plus j'ai de chance
de faire un nul
de le faire tout de suite je voulais
faire H4 avant l'échange de tour mais
bon peu importe
d'être nulle
pourquoi pas mais il va falloir
on imagine bien
puis c'est facile on joue tous au même
niveau dans l'équipe évidemment
surprise
il veut jouer quoi en fait le manger
il y a beaucoup de pions où est-ce qu'il
veut juste possible
et tu ne bouges plus en fait et pendant
ce temps là
genre je te dis en fait je fais tout à 7
et comment est-ce que tu bouges parce
que
je fais à 6
et si tu bouges pour sortir du globe je
prends et je fais et je gagne
et du coup en fait tu ne peux pas
sortir de ce clouage là et surtout en
fait et ben c'est ma tour contrôle si tu
veux tes deux pièces
donc c'est comme si en fait j'ai pas de
pièce de moi
c'est beaucoup attention quand même
parce que tu vois si je vais sur case
noire avec mon roi dans ce cas là je
suis un peu Jojo
mais je joue pas tout à
OK
oui bon
j'aime bien le fait de d'enlever les
possibilités d'adversaire donc j'aime
plutôt
en fait je pense que maintenant tout
gagne ça gagne très facilement une très
belle conversion de Digne il va il va
moins galérer avec ce qu'il a choisi
monstrueux encore une partie de dingue
parce que c'est pas fait exprès
tu vois même pour les blagues c'est le
hasard encore une fois enfin tu lance un
dé et c'est pour ça ah oui mais bon le
hasard ça fait toute ma vie depuis que
je suis né j'ai de la chance dans tout
ce que je fais donc j'ai pas fait exprès
de dire que de dire qu'il avait un
niveau de dingue c'était pas du tout
volontaire mais au final ça ça arrive ça
arrive bien là
ne dis pas fait exprès c'était prévu
depuis le début du stream
[Musique]
alors du coup bon maintenant sur les
deux premières enfin les deux échiquiers
des deux leaders ou des deux grands
favoris digne et Carlson on sait que ça
va passer saut et réalisé sa tendrait
plutôt vers la nul Abdou karwana plutôt
vers la nul si karwana confirme que
c'est bien une sorte de forteresse et
vente forest rapporte ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas vu vent de Forest
de loin et j'ai l'impression que il se
passe pas grand chose si il y a quand
même une pression sur un petit peu de
cartes qui peut tomber
très désagréable
tu verras confirme par cette par cette
partie
possible je le vois finir par cette
dans le stream je pense que les autres
vont être assez
possible oui je pense que après
j'ai vu que
à tenter de
[Musique]
d'envoyer son roi à la chasse
il a tenté de gagner tour 4 contre tour
3 en activant son roi et en rentrant son
roi dans le camp adverse donc on peut
peut-être aller voir un petit peu ce
qu'il a fait souffre avec son roi pour
essayer de gagner la finale de tour
est-ce que tu es ok tu ouvres d'aller
voir ça
quelque chose regardez le roi très malin
il essaie de d'aller faire roi des 6 roi
et 7 sauf que sauf tout le monde que la
tour D1 vient couper
le roi blanc est pas facile de mettre
notre propre tour qui en G4 en jeu
un coin important est très pédagogique
qu'on voit ici tourner un ça coupe le
roi le roi c'est une pièce très très
forte en finale toujours l'active au
maximum vous voyez le roi noir bloqué
par un tour blanche et là et le roi
blanc bloqué par un tour noir
et les blancs en plus c'est eux qui
doivent
[Musique]
pas trop comment le blanc pas progresser
c'est même si tu fais pour G3 je vais
essayer de tourger trop froid voilà pour
la ouais c'est ça latéralement
il reviendront avec le roi G7
et jusqu'à tout échanger et avoir juste
un seul pion et les snacks donc
franchement c'est c'est une belle
position
belle forteresse de Caravana
je t'avoue que moi j'aurais pu apporter
la banque noir ah oui oui et puis il a
fait une finale en plus même sur les
autres aspects rentrer là-dedans c'était
dur mais tout ce qu'il a fait avant
c'était compliqué il avait une finale un
peu dégueu au début maintenant qu'on y
pense peut-être que cette idée de
forteresse il l'a eu en fait ici quoi
dans sa tête c'était ok on va essayer de
changer tout ça quoi
vaut mieux échanger les poubelles qu'en
fait dans cette position là il avait
déjà capté ce qu'il fallait faire oui je
pense que c'est de technique générale ou
bah il a su qu'il allait devoir liquider
pour faire nul tu vois sauf que YouTube
tu as l'impression finalement qu'il a
fait nul facile
[Musique]
on aurait pu imaginer à du réel mais
parce que nous on avait dit qu'il allait
gagner avec les Blancs parce que la
structure était trop dégueulasse mais
lui depuis le début il savait ouais mais
t'inquiète pas moi je vais changer ça et
puis et ça c'est ouf quoi les mecs sont
tellement forts
il y a eu un petit peu des
choses là il y a eu le petit 4
ans
[Musique]
à cause de dames prends des trois
ou jolie alors ça j'aurai ça
mais est-ce que c'est sûr
toutes les échecs intermezzo
je me prends des trois je pourrais
coincer avec mon rond en E2
voilà
il est tranquille pour l'instant
il contrôle sa position
bon et si on fait tout retrouver
deux et qu'on fait C3 c'est 2 etc ça va
être quoi
la dame centrale qu'est-ce qu'elle
contrôle bien échiquier pour
peut-être que ça oui c'est ça
c'est sûr ou pas
ouais c'est embêtant je peux jouer C3
mais
le fou prend E3 tour prend tour prends
des 5 c'est pénible
mais bon on voit rien qui s'est gardé
une bonne réserve de temps pour ajuster
sa technique ouais
il a 17 minutes contre contre une 47
pour rappel qu'il y a un rajout de temps
en 40e pour 40e coup les joueurs vont
voir 50 minutes de rajout c'est énorme
50 minutes de rajout plus qu'un coup
pour Gamer pour avoir ce rajoutant là
mais je pense pas qu'on aura beaucoup de
parties qui vont vraiment durer
longtemps parce que là je vois que sauce
a l'air
vente forest qui pourrait nous faire
finir tard tous les soirs avant de
Forest il aime bien jouer longtemps et
local ils profitent
profite du public il profite
[Musique]
donc ouais ouais bon Magnus fait le
travail il a joué ce petit haschis un
peu lunaire à mes yeux
ça fait 6 on achète pour le roi ok
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que je trouve ça un peu
lunaire ça me parle pas trop
bon en tout cas il sait pas quoi faire
avec les Blancs ça c'est malheureusement
il a dit
montre-moi ce que tu veux faire c'est
très très dur pour pour qui me
et dame j'ai 5 c'est qu'une pseudo
enfilade parce que ça me na c'est pas
grand chose quand même puisque c'est
avec la dame qu'on les attaque sera avec
un fou oui mais comme la première tour
est protégée
[Musique]
c'est dur on reste avec tour des deux
après je pense c'est une nul assez
facile en fait maintenant oui ça va on
va se dessiner
même G40
[Musique]
mais on peut tout jouer maintenant on
voit que c'est assez stable en plus il y
a pas de
il y a pas de gros problèmes pour G3
mais attention que tu auras le chien il
peut y avoir des ressources comme ça
mais à ça on verra
après
belle galère pour les blancs de trouver
quelque chose donc je vais rester stable
peut-être que sur ça il veut jouer ça ah
oui oui j'ai pas trop envie d'aller me
galérer là-dedans
me compliquer les
tours des deux stables je trouve ça me
plaît bien moi
on prouve un peu
[Musique]
ça m'a l'air un peu fou que
c'est 5
et je me rappelle que tu as proposé un
coup très intéressant au lieu de
reprendre un chiffre
on est encore une fois encore une fois
[Musique]
peut-être que ce soit la même discussion
qu'on a eu ce matin avec 45
mais j'ai composé toi à 7
c'était c'était intéressant parce que je
te mets vraiment en exemple quoi ok
alors est-ce que je dois prendre en ces
trois
je sais pas
réussisse sauf s'il te plaît j'ai envie
de jouer comme ça pour pour activer
on fait des sacrés bons coups parce que
quand on voit la jauge chaque cité et en
fait aussi hein
je pensais que c'était le quoi peut-être
du coup pour
bloquer clairement ça et même tu parles
ton bras je peux même faire ça et ça
c'est pas facile alors toi comment je
devais faire peut-être moi aussi donc ça
a pas l'air d'aller particulièrement
[Musique]
il m'a sauté aux yeux dès le début parce
que tu me clairement les blancs
et ouais encore une fois bon je joue au
hasard j'ai lancé
sur la cassette il y a pas de septième
pas ça c'est logique de fixer
l'adversaire avec toi cette Clément
tactiques et puis moi aussi bah ça ça
semblait plus précis un petit peu ce que
ce qu'a joué digne j'ai envie de jouer
pareil en me disant bah ça va
accompagner les pions là les deux il a
peut-être regardé les deux d'ailleurs
une petite review au ralenti alors le
ralenti de la partie Ding je peux te
dire que ça va te ça va quand même je te
la fais vite parce que là voilà c'est là
là c'est la review de cheesecom qui fait
automatiquement voilà ça c'est classique
espagnol arcangle avec le fouet 5 qui
vise de contrôler pour paramaxodlu le
centre blanc en construction de loin
avec le fou qui est pas en E7 comme ça
se fait dans les Espagnols traditionnel
donc ce fou là il travaille sur le
centre
on va voir ensuite que Max doudou mais
c'est fou en relation pour attaquer le
centre et là petit sacrifice ou en tout
cas il est intéressant on vient donner
deux pièces mineures pour une qualité
pour une tour
avec l'idée de d'ouvrir totalement la
position
et il y a eu un grand moment dans
l'ouverture de position pour valoriser
la tour contre les pièces mineures c'est
ce moment là où la tour centrale en E5 a
fait extrêmement mal à mazout qui aurait
dû laisser la position plus fermée il a
voulu l'ouvrir pour ses fous mais les
fous se sont mis trop tard en chemin
dans cette position et du coup ça a été
extrêmement dur on a laissé des plumes
et là faut F7 pour calmer pour prendre
F7 et la finale qu'on a là avec on va
prendre un 6 et
un bon plus blanc quand même dans cette
position max doudou va souffrir même si
le coup de stouffe était plus précis
tout à 7
quand même pas mal de chances de gains
pour pour Ding qui a quand même quatre
pions pour la pièce c'est beaucoup ça va
être ça va quand même dur mais ça va
durer plus longtemps que prévu s'il
avait vu le coup de souffle
surtout avec le temps comme ça qui
restait au 2 joueurs c'était chaud alors
Magnus
je sais pas si j'ai une caméra sur sur
les joueurs parce que bon caméra marche
pas trop j'ai une caméra sur si vous
voulez
sur gamer qui
a pas l'air extrêmement content
non ça c'est sûr même si c'est que
il joue le King
il aimerait bien faire
mieux que ce qu'il a fait avec les
Blancs parce que finalement si on prend
cette partie il s'est fait quand même
dominer peut-être depuis le 15e coup
avec les Blancs
donc du 15 au 40e là il a fait que
souffrir
c'est vraiment une galère cette partie
extrêmement difficile je pense que là il
va il va abandonner
en ce qui l'attend peut-être que grâce à
une revienne à la table pour abandonner
parce que là on a zéro coup
c'est pas facile oui
à 4 je commence juste pour terminer tu
veux juste ça ça
c'est très très dur parce que les deux
pions B2 et foodéca peut-être des choses
comme ça
pas plus simple
trop
là il viendrait pas prendre la tour
évidemment
il pourrait peut-être jouer un petit
tour 2
et ça continue encore donc je dois avoir
un gain encore plus simple
c'est une bonne tête quand même déjà
ces trois tours C4
bon voilà puis après le roi qui va
arriver autour des 1 tour des trois
peut-être
et après j'amène mon roi
jusqu'en D4 j'ai gagné
yes voilà c'est
ici
encore pire parce que là du coup elle a
deux pions qui a qui va avancer
lointaines aujourd'hui
j'ai vu sur mes mails j'ai commencé à
avoir quelques parties d'élèves qui sont
arrivés
je pense que ça a été fortune diverses
comme à chaque fois tout le monde peut
pas gagner mais est-ce que c'est bien
passé tu as une carte GB tu nous fais un
petit sourire donc ça a l'air d'être
plutôt bon je pense qu'il a dû gagner il
vient comme ça avec le sourire ceux qui
viennent chanter dans le chat après leur
partie généralement c'est bien passé
puisque sinon c'est un peu c'est un peu
dur yes j'ai gagné
ouais trop dur pour trop trop dur pour
Vincent Kemer on va pouvoir l'abandonner
dans sa situation
l'équipe a fait 4 4 ok il y a eu un
échange de pions ici donc il y a plus de
4 pions pour la pour pour
une bonne nouvelle les quatre pions pour
pour digne il va technifier il a en plus
son rajout de temps
avoir 50 minutes en plus c'est juste un
mini regarde
et qui va
[Musique]
qui va venir s'asseoir je pense que
gamer va abandonner dans la foulée bravo
gaillard qui nous disent j'ai gagné mon
équipe aussi